Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 30, FPGAs. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so, you know, I'm a big fan of board games as is Patrick and been playing a lot of board games lately on the phone you mean like like monopoly actually do they have an op oh no you know what I looked into
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供主机服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 30 期，FPGA。Jason，开始吧。嘿，你知道，我和 Patrick 一样都是棋盘游戏的忠实粉丝，最近在手机上玩了很多棋盘游戏，你是说像大富翁那样的吗？其实他们有大富翁吗？哦不，你知道吗，我研究过
monopoly on the phone but it it got terrible reviews like a bunch people are like the app crashes there's like micro transactions in monopoly which that sounds horrible yeah no i was joking i was joking most people think board games monopoly not good i don't like board games yeah that's right that is sort of the flow it's like let me think board games equals monopoly equals me sitting around for three hours while the two people left you know finish the game equals equals not fun but uh yeah so i've been playing uh ticket to ride it's been pretty awesome uh patrick's been playing carcassonne or carcassonne depending on i won't try to pronounce it i play several board games on my phone uh i like this card game dominion oh yeah dominion's great i didn't know
手机版大富翁，但评价很差，很多人说应用会崩溃，而且大富翁里还有微交易，听起来太糟糕了。是啊，我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的。大多数人想到棋盘游戏就会想到大富翁，觉得不好玩。我不喜欢棋盘游戏。是的，没错，这就是那种流程，就像是，让我想想，棋盘游戏等于大富翁，等于我坐在那儿干等三个小时，直到剩下的两个人（你知道的）结束游戏，等于等于没意思。但，是的，所以我一直在玩《车票之旅》（Ticket to Ride），真的很棒。Patrick 一直在玩《卡卡颂》（Carcassonne），或者叫卡卡颂，取决于……我不会试着去读那个名字。我在手机上玩过好几种棋盘游戏，我喜欢这个叫《领土》（Dominion）的卡牌游戏。哦，是的，Dominion 很棒，我不知道
they can play it really fast. I don't know. I have an iPhone, so I can play it on my iPhone. Oh, I see. Is Dominion, is it free? Yeah. Well, I have a version I downloaded a long time ago that was free. Supposedly, the guy was going to stop doing it when they actually released a real Dominion.
他们玩得那么快。我不知道。我用的是 iPhone，所以我可以在 iPhone 上玩。哦，我明白了。Dominion 是免费的吗？是的。嗯，我很久以前下载过一个版本，是免费的。据说，当他们真正发布正式版 Dominion 时，那个人就会停止维护这个版本。
But I don't know if that's ever happened. That they've released a free one or that he... So they were they were gonna make an official the people who would officially license dominion oh i see i see but they haven't done that yet yeah i don't i don't know if they did gotcha gotcha yeah they um uh they're really fun i mean it's uh the bad thing about ticket to ride is uh so you can either do pass and play which i've been doing my wife or like you know you use a tablet and you know i put some trains down i pass it over to her right um the online play it forces you to play with strangers which i think is is a terrible design decision i mean i think the problem is you know you think about it right who makes a board game
但我不知道这事儿发生过没有。他们发布了免费版，还是他……所以他们打算做一个官方版本，就是那些获得 Dominion 官方授权的人。哦，我明白了，我明白了。但他们还没做出来。是的，我不知道他们做没做。明白了，明白了。是的，它们……它们真的很有趣。我是说，Ticket to Ride 的坏处是，你可以选择“传递并游玩”（pass and play），我一直和我妻子这么玩，或者你知道，用平板电脑，我放一些火车，然后传给她，对吧。嗯，在线对战强制你和陌生人玩，我觉得这是一个糟糕的设计决策。我是说，我觉得问题在于，你想想看，谁会制作棋盘游戏？
somebody who is like pretty into like math techie like like like game theory kind of stuff whatever those people you know would never want to play with friends they'd always want to play like ranked like that's what they have is like this ranked game system where i'm being matched up with somebody from from a pool of three people probably want to play tickets to ride i'm being matched up with... You should mention this is only on Android. On iOS, you can actually play with your friends. Really?
那些非常沉迷于数学、技术，或者像游戏理论之类东西的人，无论如何，这些人永远不会想和朋友玩，他们总是想玩排位赛。这就是他们所拥有的，这种排位赛系统，我被匹配到三个可能想玩 Ticket to Ride 的人中的一个，我被匹配到……你应该提一下这只在 Android 上才有。在 iOS 上，你实际上可以和朋友一起玩。真的吗？
Yes. Oh, man. Yeah, so specifically the Android is literally a copy of the web version. So, yeah, they're using like... You know how Adobe has this thing thing called flex i think it's called flex or air or something like that air yeah air yeah where you write code and it works on the web and on the phone so so these guys are using that i believe um and uh and yeah so so on the web as well you can't pick people to play again so for all the people who are extremely confused
是的。天哪。是的，所以 Android 版实际上就是网页版的复制品。所以，是的，他们使用的是……你知道 Adobe 有个东西叫 Flex，我想是叫 Flex 或 Air 之类的，Air，是的，Air，是的，你在那上面写代码，它就能在网页和手机上运行。所以，我相信这些家伙就是用的那个。而且，是的，所以在网页上你也无法选择和谁对战。所以对于所有那些感到非常困惑的人
about jason talking about putting trains down on a board because you don't know what this ticket to ride game is yeah it's a board game that they made an iphone or now an android version of and they also have an iphone ipad version ios version and a web version apparently which has been out for a while so how do you like playing so you do you have the board game the actual board game no so so i used to um play board games with a group of guys uh back when i lived on the east coast and uh we all kind of split the cost by buying different board games each and so i did not have the ticket to ride game and i still oh okay okay but you have played the physical version oh yeah a bunch of times have you uh do
关于 Jason 谈论在棋盘上放火车，因为你不知道这个 Ticket to Ride 游戏是什么。是的，这是一款棋盘游戏，他们制作了 iPhone 版，或者现在有了 Android 版，他们还有 iPhone/iPad 版、iOS 版，显然还有一个已经推出一段时间的网页版。那么你喜欢玩吗？你有这款棋盘游戏的实体版吗？没有，所以我过去常和一群朋友玩棋盘游戏，那时我住在东海岸，我们大家分摊费用，每人买不同的棋盘游戏，所以我没有 Ticket to Ride 的游戏，我仍然……哦，好吧，好吧，但你玩过实体版。哦，是的，玩过很多次。你有……
you have that ticket to ride i do i do i have uh i have the ticket to ride i was amazed how mainstream ticket to ride is like it's in walmart and target now yeah that's right that's right so how do you feel like the differences between playing it on a tablet phone versus actually moving the pieces and sitting around a table yeah so so for all of these board games it is way better on the phone on electronic version i'm just i'm just so much i mean it's almost to the point where uh uh you know if they made tablets just a little bit bigger i would just play it on the tablet like even with a group of four people rather than really yeah so i find it depends on the game yeah so like but like ticket to ride isn't that much upkeep
你有那个 Ticket to Ride 吗？我有，我有，我有 Ticket to Ride。我很惊讶 Ticket to Ride 竟然这么主流，现在沃尔玛和塔吉特都有卖。是的，没错，没错。那么你觉得在平板电脑/手机上玩和实际移动棋子、围坐在桌子旁有什么区别？是的，所以对于所有这些棋盘游戏，手机上的电子版要好得多。我只是……我是说，这几乎到了这种程度，如果平板电脑再大一点，我甚至会直接在平板电脑上玩，哪怕是四个人一起玩，而不是……真的吗？是的，所以我发现这取决于游戏。是的，比如 Ticket to Ride 并没有那么多的维护工作
in rules and math that you have to get right. So I actually prefer playing it in person, I think. And people have more fun and conversations. When you play on your phone, even if with people in the same room, everybody's really focused and trying to do their thing. And so it gets kind of quiet. People don't tend to converse as much.
在规则和数学方面，你必须得搞对。所以我实际上更喜欢面对面玩，我想。人们会玩得更开心，交流更多。当你用手机玩时，即使和同屋的人一起，每个人也都非常专注，试图做自己的事。所以会变得有点安静。人们往往不会交流那么多。
But then other games that I've played that require, like Dominion, I was saying, there's a lot of shuffling you have to do and stuff. So it's actually really nice on the phone because they just do all that for you, so you can just play very quickly. So you can get a game in against a computer or a random person or a friend in like five minutes
但其他我玩过的游戏，比如我刚才说的 Dominion，需要做很多洗牌之类的工作。所以手机上其实非常好，因为它们会自动为你处理这些，所以你可以玩得非常快。所以你可以在五分钟内和电脑、随机玩家或朋友玩上一局
versus 20 minutes or 30 minutes. Yeah, definitely. I mean, of course, the elephant in the room here, right, is being able to create the desktop experience using these devices, right? Like, if each person at the table has a phone, a smartphone, and there's a tablet or maybe even two tablets in the center of the table, there's no reason why you couldn't, you know, recreate the same exact experience just you know electronically like in the sense that like the phones would just have
而不是 20 分钟或 30 分钟。是的，绝对。我是说，当然，这里显而易见的问题是，能够使用这些设备创造桌面体验，对吧？比如，如果桌上的每个人都有手机，智能手机，并且桌子中间有一台平板电脑，甚至两台平板电脑，没有理由不能，你知道，以电子方式重现完全相同的体验，就像手机上只有
the cards that you'd be but that's like the world's most expensive board game oh yeah yeah you have to assume that people already have all of this stuff otherwise yeah it breaks down but but the thing is your point is valid that like the uh it's true when we do the pass and play we're not talking quite as much, when we do the pass and play, we're not talking quite as much as when we're playing the board game. But I think that's more just a fact of you just have to kind of keep passing it back and forth. It's not really like a board game where it's just kind of always there. It always feels like one person has to be paying attention
你拥有的卡牌，但这就像是世界上最昂贵的棋盘游戏。哦，是的，是的，你得假设人们已经有了所有这些东西，否则它就没法玩了。但关键是你的观点是成立的，确实，当我们进行“传递并游玩”时，我们交流得没那么多了，当我们进行“传递并游玩”时，我们交流得没那么多了，不像我们玩实体棋盘游戏时那样。但我认为这更多是因为你必须不断地把它传来传去。它不像棋盘游戏那样一直放在那儿。总感觉必须有一个人时刻关注着
versus a board game everyone can step away, right? Oh, yeah. i don't know but they have pros and cons i don't think they replace each other but i like to have them both yeah it makes sense i mean for uh more complex games like uh always like agricola you know with all those pieces and the putting the fences and the pigs and dealing with all that it's like that would be so much easier and then computing the score at the end always took like 20 minutes you know that's true so what you need is an app where you just take a picture of the configuration of the board at the end and then it scores it for you yeah yeah definitely or like if you're really bad at chess you have like a chess app that you like take a picture of the chess board and it recommends the next move for you that'd be awesome so when you're when the guy you're playing you know sneezes you just like
而棋盘游戏每个人都可以走开，对吧？哦，是的。我不知道，但它们各有优缺点，我不认为它们能互相取代，但我喜欢两者都有。是的，这很有道理。我是说，对于更复杂的游戏，比如 Agricola，你知道，有那么多棋子，还要放栅栏、放猪，处理所有这些，那会容易得多。而且最后计算分数总是要花 20 分钟，你知道的。那倒是真的。所以你需要的是一个应用程序，你只需要在最后给棋盘的布局拍张照，然后它就为你计分。是的，是的，绝对。或者如果你下棋很烂，你有一个国际象棋应用，你可以给棋盘拍张照，它会为你推荐下一步棋，那太棒了。所以当和你对弈的那个人打喷嚏时，你只需要
whip it out real quick take a picture and have you seen this where uh anyone can beat a grandmaster in chess just by having like two grandmasters in a room and the person playing the you know opposite grandmasters move anyways you know what i mean like like you have two grandmasters you're playing both of them the first the one on the right makes a move and you make the same move to the one on the left like eventually oh so you'll win one of the two games against a grandmaster yeah exactly yeah okay yes so uh yeah okay a pretty cool thing is uh just we'll get off the subject is vassal um it's kind of clunky i wouldn't recommend it unless you got a little bit of techie skills um wait they're
迅速掏出来拍张照。你见过这个吗？任何人都可以通过在房间里放两个特级大师，然后让对弈的人走（你知道的）对方特级大师的棋，从而击败国际象棋特级大师。总之，你知道我的意思吗？就像你有两个特级大师，你和他们两个对弈，右边的那个人走了一步，你就对左边的那个人走同样的一步，最终……哦，所以你会在对阵特级大师的两局比赛中赢下一局。是的，完全正确。好的，是的，所以……好的，一件很酷的事情是……我们先偏离一下主题，是 Vassal，它有点笨重，除非你有一点技术能力，否则我不推荐它……等等，他们
listening to our podcast yeah well i guess what i'm saying is don't recommend this to you know your friends who don't know anything about programming or anything like that um you know because most people would want to play this with other people and And so if you want to play this with other people, you'll probably have to go to their house and set this up, which is kind of unfortunate. But it's pretty cool. It lets you play over the Internet. And basically what they've done is they have a bunch of board games,
在听我们的播客。是的，好吧，我想说的是，不要把这个推荐给你那些对编程一窍不通的朋友，或者类似的人。因为大多数人会想和别人一起玩，所以如果你想和别人一起玩，你可能得去他们家设置这个，这有点不幸。但它很酷。它让你通过互联网玩。基本上他们所做的是，他们有一堆棋盘游戏，
like probably 100-something board games, and they literally have just taken pictures of all the cards and the board and all and the board and all the pieces and they don't have any of the game logic in vassal but they just have the the resources so in other words um if you're playing monopoly like on vassal you can just put a house anywhere on the board it's as if you're really playing a board i mean there's nothing stopping you from physically putting a house somewhere even if it doesn't make any sense right so it's very open-ended and it supports many different games and you have to kind of enforce the rules
大概 100 多种棋盘游戏，他们真的只是把所有的卡牌、棋盘和所有的棋子都拍了照，他们在 Vassal 中没有任何游戏逻辑，但他们拥有这些资源。换句话说，如果你在 Vassal 上玩大富翁，你可以把房子放在棋盘上的任何地方，就好像你真的在玩棋盘一样。我是说，没有什么能阻止你物理上把房子放在某个地方，即使这没有任何意义，对吧？所以它非常开放，支持许多不同的游戏，你必须自己强制执行规则
yourself but uh it does let you play a ton of board games online which is i think it's pretty nice nice all right i'm gonna have to check that out i haven't tried that before yeah totally all right so on to the news our first news topic seems to have been very controversial online, and that is this new product called Coin, which is at onlycoin.com, where Coin is a revolutionary new credit card device, or just card device, I guess. And the idea is that it is a small electronic thing that is the same exact size as a normal credit card, rewards card, driver's license, this kind of thing.
但它确实让你可以在线玩大量的棋盘游戏，我觉得这很不错。好的，好的，我得去看看，我以前没试过。是的，完全同意。好的，那么进入新闻环节。我们的第一个新闻话题似乎在网上引起了很大争议，那就是这个叫 Coin 的新产品，网址是 onlycoin.com，Coin 是一款革命性的新型信用卡设备，或者说卡片设备，我想是这样。它的理念是，它是一个小型电子产品，大小和普通的信用卡、奖励卡、驾照之类的东西完全一样。
And on your phone, you take a picture of the front and back of the card and then you run it through a little card reader that they send to you. Similar if you've ever seen like the square device is what I imagine it being. Cause it's not out yet you swipe it then it kind of knows what's on the magnetic stripe and it has pictures of the front and back then you can sync from your phone via bluetooth to this device and have up to i
在手机上，你给卡片的正面和背面拍张照，然后通过他们寄给你的小读卡器刷一下。如果你见过 Square 设备的话，我想象它就是那样的。因为它还没上市，你刷一下，它就知道磁条上有什么，并且有正面和背面的图片，然后你可以通过蓝牙从手机同步到这个设备，最多可以有……
think it says eight cards where at the push of a button on the front there's a little screen embedded and when you push button you can cycle through your cards and then if you want to use your debit card you select the debit card and swipe uh you know if you want to use your credit card you punch this button again and you know it's your credit card you can swipe so how does this what's the connection between this and the phone so the idea is that the phone is needed because if somebody wants to see that you actually own the card, I guess, and also that like, you know, prove you have the card, then you want to have that on the phone. Also, the phone is what's used to transmit the details of what the card like how to be that card. Oh, right, right, right. I see what you're right so like um on the magnet i don't know that much about it but like the magnetic swipe of these cards like the strip on the back that the dark color typically
我想它说的是八张卡，在正面的按钮按一下，有一个嵌入的小屏幕，当你按按钮时，你可以循环切换你的卡片，然后如果你想用借记卡，你就选择借记卡并刷卡……你知道，如果你想用信用卡，你再按一下这个按钮，你知道，这就是你的信用卡，你可以刷卡。那么这个和手机之间的连接是什么？所以理念是，手机是必需的，因为如果有人想看你是否真的拥有这张卡，我想，而且还要证明你有这张卡，那么你就会想在手机上有这个。此外，手机还用于传输卡片的详细信息，比如如何模拟那张卡。哦，对，对，对。我明白了，你是对的，所以就像……在磁条上……我对这个了解不多，但就像这些卡的磁刷……背面的条纹，通常是深色的
has magnetic particles that are i don't think they're encoded or encrypted very well i mean encoded somehow but they're not encrypted very strongly and basically when you swipe it some pattern comes off that is like the card number what the card is and your name and your billing address or something like just a few items or something as well right the what the cvv those three no oh yeah yeah or maybe in like the expiration date but like just a string and so if you have a mag reader like square or something else you can basically just get clear text basically what's on the front of the card by just swiping right so this device presumably will reprogram the magnetic stripe to whatever you've selected when you push the button and then when you swipe it through the reader will just think that card
有磁性颗粒，我不认为它们被编码或加密得很好。我是说以某种方式编码，但它们加密得不是很强。基本上当你刷卡时，会产生一种模式，就像卡号、卡片是什么、你的名字和账单地址，或者只是几项内容之类的。对，CVV，那三个……不，哦，是的，是的，或者可能是过期日期，但只是一个字符串。所以如果你有一个磁卡阅读器，比如 Square 或其他什么，你基本上可以通过刷卡直接获得卡片正面的明文。所以这个设备大概会把你按按钮时选择的任何内容重新编程到磁条上，然后当你把它刷过读卡器时，它就会认为那张卡
was swiped through that's awesome so um is there anything about how much it'll cost or anything so i oh i I forgot now. Oh, actually, I'm on the website now. You can preorder. If you preorder, it's $55. If you know, once it is launched, that it's $105. Okay. Yeah.
被刷过了。那太棒了。那么，关于它要花多少钱之类的有什么说法吗？所以我……哦，我忘了。哦，实际上，我现在在网站上。你可以预订。如果你预订，是 55 美元。如果你知道，一旦它发布，就是 105 美元。好的。是的。
So there's it seems really interesting. But people have like a lot of concerns, I guess, legitimate or not. But that has like it seems pretty legitimate. Like it doesn't seem like a, of concerns i guess legitimate or not but uh that has like it seems pretty legitimate like it doesn't seem like a you know obvious scam it's backed by some pretty big companies and vc firms um and they weird thing is though is that they require you to prepay your pre-order so this is slightly similar to kickstarter but like if kickstarter doesn't succeed you don't pay but if it does then you pay and eventually get your item but normally when you pre-order something
所以这看起来真的很有趣。但人们有很多顾虑，我想，无论是否合理。但这看起来相当合理。它看起来不像是一个……顾虑，我想，无论是否合理，但这看起来相当合理。它看起来不像是一个……你知道，明显的骗局，它有几家相当大的公司和风投公司支持。嗯，奇怪的是，他们要求你预付预订款，所以这有点类似于 Kickstarter，但如果 Kickstarter 不成功，你不用付钱，但如果成功了，你就付钱，最终得到你的物品。但通常当你预订某样东西时
you pay when it ships but here they're collecting it up front so you pay now so they can do all their manufacturing and it doesn't as far as i can tell like i mean they have prototypes but it doesn't exist yet right right so as with anything there's a risk and there's also a risk that you know like if you go to a restaurant and the person takes your card like they could in theory switch to a different card on purpose or by accident um yeah but that doesn't help them in here does it i mean no but like uh people have these and also like accepting it right like i don't know what this is this isn't visa or mastercard like oh Like, where do I?
你会在发货时付款，但这里他们是预先收取，所以你现在付款，这样他们就可以进行所有的制造工作。而且据我所知，他们有原型，但它还不存在，对吧？对，对。所以和任何事情一样，都有风险。而且还有一种风险，你知道，比如如果你去餐馆，服务员拿走了你的卡，理论上他们可以故意或意外地切换到另一张卡。嗯，是的，但这在这里对他们没帮助，不是吗？我是说，不，但就像……人们有这些，而且还有接受度的问题，对吧？比如，我不知道这是什么，这不是 Visa 或万事达卡，就像……哦，比如，我在哪里用？
So there's just like, it'll be, at least initially, there'll be a lot of uncertainty from people. But it would be nice to get rid of all the extra cards, right? Like, and just carry one card. You know, you're absolutely right. Like, think about this. You know, your debit card, as everyone knows, is much less secure than a credit card.
所以，至少在初期，人们会有很多不确定性。但如果能摆脱所有多余的卡片，那不是很好吗？比如，只带一张卡。你知道，你是完全正确的。比如，想想看。你的借记卡，正如每个人所知，安全性远低于信用卡。
It's actually very hard to reverse a transaction on your debit card whereas it's it's almost trivial on a credit card um so somebody could say at a restaurant you know artificially add to your bill uh like somehow scam you that way and then switch it to your debit card and uh you know what i mean like like and then it would be harder to get your money back yeah so i mean that's one concern they have some nifty safety features like if the card gets too far away from your phone it could auto disable or send an alert to your phone so that you like okay like that's a cool feature i guess that's true if they have the phone the phone can always like they could always have a button that says you know lock my card so yeah that's what i was thinking like a valet mode or
在借记卡上撤销交易实际上非常困难，而在信用卡上几乎是小菜一碟。所以有人在餐馆里可能会说，你知道，人为地增加你的账单，比如以某种方式诈骗你，然后把它切换到你的借记卡上，而且……你知道我的意思吗？比如，然后你再想拿回钱就更难了。是的，所以这是他们担心的点。他们有一些巧妙的安全功能，比如如果卡片离你的手机太远，它可以自动禁用或向你的手机发送警报，这样你就会……好的，这功能很酷，我想。确实，如果他们有手机，手机总是可以……他们总是可以有一个按钮说“锁定我的卡”，所以是的，我就是这么想的，比如代客泊车模式或
whatever like yeah so like they could disable it from changing or yeah you disable it completely or just disable yeah there's like you said disable it from changing but like like one of the things so there's been other startups that are attempting to do similar style things um and some of them it's by essentially you swipe one card and then they hold some pool of money and then you can select on kind of like the backend what card you want it to go to, which is a very different thing and has other problems.
什么的，比如……是的，所以他们可以禁用它更改，或者……是的，你完全禁用它，或者只是禁用……是的，就像你说的，禁用它更改。但就像……其中一件事，还有其他初创公司试图做类似风格的事情，其中一些是通过你基本上刷一张卡，然后他们持有一笔资金池，然后你可以在后端选择你想让它转到哪张卡，这完全是另一回事，而且有其他问题。
But one of the nice things about that is that that website can then track all of your purchases across all of your cards. Versus like this coin thing, you can't track your purchases because it knows it got swiped but it doesn't for instance know how much money was charged because they're not a part of the actual transaction yeah that makes sense so we'll see it's definitely interesting uh i i like to see people innovating in this area because it's the current credit card stuff isn't
但其中一个好处是，那个网站可以跟踪你在所有卡片上的所有消费。而像这个 Coin，你无法跟踪你的消费，因为它知道它被刷了，但它不知道例如扣了多少钱，因为他们不是实际交易的一部分。是的，这说得通。所以我们走着瞧，这绝对很有趣。我喜欢看到人们在这个领域创新，因为目前的信用卡东西并不
that great so yeah right definitely yeah i mean you think about it if they get this right you almost don't need a wallet anymore i mean if you get it down to only needing two cards maybe there's like a better you know carrying you know utensil for that right i mean the wallet in general but where am i going to put the pictures of my kids on your phone okay yeah okay that works the the next uh news article dart turns 1.0 so we talked about dart i believe we did a whole show on dart pretty sure yes yeah and uh you know we're both big fans i'm a very very big fan. I think Dart is amazing. I have had to write a lot of JavaScript.
那么好。所以，是的，没错，绝对。我是说，你想想，如果他们做对了，你几乎不再需要钱包了。我是说，如果你把它精简到只需要两张卡，也许有更好的携带工具，对吧？我是说钱包整体，但我把孩子们的照片放在哪里？在你的手机上。好的，是的，好的，那行得通。下一条新闻，Dart 达到 1.0 版本。我们谈论过 Dart，我相信我们做过一整期关于 Dart 的节目，我很确定。是的，是的，而且……你知道我们都是大粉丝，我是个非常非常大的粉丝。我觉得 Dart 很棒。我不得不写很多 JavaScript。
And I found recently there's some good tools that make JavaScript a little easier in terms of, you know, there's a tool called Typecast, which is pretty nice. I think we might have talked about it. But Dart kind of gives you a lot of these things, and it gives you a really nice set of batteries, as we always say. There's a plenty of batteries included in Dart, such as hash maps and lists and all these great things, even tree sets, ordered maps, etc. So it turns 1.0, which is pretty awesome. This article that we've linked to talks a lot about the different features of Dart. The common criticism of Dart is that it just doesn't have that widespread adoption.
我最近发现有一些很好的工具让 JavaScript 变得容易了一些，比如，有一个叫 Typecast 的工具，非常不错。我想我们可能谈论过它。但 Dart 给了你很多这些东西，而且它给了你一套非常好的“电池”，正如我们常说的。Dart 中内置了充足的电池，比如哈希映射、列表和所有这些伟大的东西，甚至树集、有序映射等等。所以它达到了 1.0 版本，这非常棒。我们链接的这篇文章谈论了很多 Dart 的不同特性。对 Dart 的普遍批评是它没有得到广泛采用。
I mean, it has this critical mass problem, right, where you have just so much infrastructure built in JavaScript. And even though Dart 1.0 makes it much easier to access JavaScript code from Dart, you just, it still is just, you know, it's incredible, there's an incredible amount of inertia to move people off of JavaScript. I mean, it doesn't matter what the alternative would be. I mean, if you look at popular alternatives to JavaScript, they are almost always just small enhancements to JavaScript, like TypeScript, which compiles to JavaScript, CoffeeScript, which compiles to JavaScript, so on and so forth. So this is, you know, this is pretty difficult. But, you know, I believe strongly this is just a really great language. And, you know, we'll hopefully see it continue to get adoption. Are there any other browsers besides Chrome that can run dart natively yet um i don't think so and in fact uh you can't
我是说，它有这种临界质量问题，对吧？你拥有那么多建立在 JavaScript 上的基础设施。即使 Dart 1.0 让从 Dart 访问 JavaScript 代码变得容易得多，你只是……它仍然只是……你知道，令人难以置信，人们从 JavaScript 迁移出来的惯性非常大。我是说，替代方案是什么并不重要。我是说，如果你看看 JavaScript 的流行替代方案，它们几乎总是只是 JavaScript 的小增强，比如 TypeScript，它编译成 JavaScript；CoffeeScript，它编译成 JavaScript，等等。所以这……你知道，这非常困难。但，你知道，我坚信这真的是一种非常棒的语言。而且，你知道，我们希望看到它继续获得采用。除了 Chrome 之外，还有其他浏览器可以原生运行 Dart 吗？嗯，我不这么认为，事实上……你也不能
run dart natively in chrome either so um yeah there's a special version of chrome that you can download which does let you run Dart natively but for one reason or another it's still not part of part of the regular Chrome okay yeah so there's actually no browser which lets you do that but looking right now to see
在 Chrome 中原生运行 Dart。所以……嗯，是的，有一个你可以下载的特殊版本的 Chrome，它确实让你原生运行 Dart，但由于某种原因，它仍然不是常规 Chrome 的一部分。好的，是的，所以实际上没有浏览器让你这样做。但现在看看
if I don't think that you know Firefox or any of the so it says that yeah so currently when you part of the so it says that yeah so currently when you uh part of the dart software development kit is a version of chrome chromium that dartium yeah oh a version of chromium i see oh yeah right this red right no worries but but yeah the uh uh you know i i don't really know why uh i mean i could only guess guess that maybe they're having trouble with mobile or something. I have no idea.
如果……我不认为 Firefox 或任何……所以它说……是的，所以目前当你……Dart 软件开发工具包的一部分是一个版本的 Chrome，Chromium，那个 Dartium。哦，一个版本的 Chromium，我明白了。哦，是的，没错，没关系。但……是的，那个……你知道，我真的不知道为什么……我是说，我只能猜测，也许他们在移动端遇到了麻烦之类的。我不知道。
To finish that thought, you can convert your Dart code to JavaScript using this thing called Dart to JS. Then it will run in any modern browser. Nice. Yeah, very cool so the next article we have is a successful ability of a qubit to last for 39 minutes so is that the guy here i hear i hear around the applause is that the guy who jumps from block to block changing the colors and and swears when he gets hit. Wait, that's Qbert, isn't it? Oh, you're absolutely right. Yeah, close, but not quite.
完成那个想法，你可以使用这个叫 Dart to JS 的东西将你的 Dart 代码转换为 JavaScript。然后它就可以在任何现代浏览器中运行。不错。是的，非常酷。所以下一篇文章是关于量子比特（qubit）持续 39 分钟的成功能力。那是那个家伙吗？我听到……我听到周围有掌声，那是那个在方块之间跳跃、改变颜色，并在被击中时骂人的家伙吗？等等，那是 Qbert，对吧？哦，你是完全正确的。是的，很接近，但不完全是。
So a qubit is the name for a quantum bit, and I'm probably going to butcher this because I've always wanted to learn more about quantum computing and computers and have never successfully managed to make heads or tails of it. So if you have a normal bit, it can be zero or one. But in quantum physics and in quantum events,
所以量子比特是量子位的名称，我可能会把这个搞砸，因为我一直想了解更多关于量子计算和计算机的知识，但从来没有成功地弄明白过。所以如果你有一个普通的位，它可以是 0 或 1。但在量子物理学和量子事件中，
you can have things that are not just unknown, like you don't know if there's zero and one, but actually exist in both zero and one with some probability. Right. And so if you have that, it's called a superposition. So it's unknown. And it's really easy for something to interact with this particle or this qubit that is in this superposition to interact with it.
你可以拥有不仅仅是未知的东西，比如你不知道它是 0 还是 1，而是实际上以某种概率同时存在于 0 和 1 中。对。所以如果你有那个，它被称为叠加态。所以它是未知的。而且很容易让某些东西与这个粒子或这个处于叠加态的量子比特相互作用。
And once something interacts with it, essentially you've made a measurement of what the state actually is and the superposition collapses. And now you have an actual either zero or one yeah so let me let me maybe like are you gonna do better here we go no no i'll just come up with it so a lot of people don't understand quantum mechanics and someone explained it to me in a way that's kind of morbid but actually made a lot of sense to me is uh like let's say you completely cut off ties to, say, your grandmother, for example, right? Assuming your grandmother is alive. Then, as soon as you do that, your grandmother is, like, 99.99% alive,
一旦有东西与它相互作用，本质上你就对它的实际状态进行了测量，叠加态就坍缩了。现在你就有了一个实际的 0 或 1。是的，所以让我……让我也许……你会做得更好吗？我们开始吧。不，不，我只是想出来。所以很多人不理解量子力学，有人以一种有点病态但实际上对我很有意义的方式向我解释了它。是……比如，假设你完全切断了与，比如，你祖母的联系，对吧？假设你祖母还活着。那么，一旦你那样做了，你祖母就是，比如，99.99% 活着，
but, like, some small, like, epsilon, you know, like, 0.0001% dead. Like, she's in the superposition state where she's part dead because you don't know if she's alive or dead now if you never speak to your grandmother for let's say 80 years and let's say assume you're young enough where you can live 80 years and still be around then your grandmother you don't know that she's dead but she's in a new superposition state where she's you know 99.999 percent dead and you know some small percent alive right because most people don't live to whatever she would be let's say 180 right so extremely rare so once you go and visit her or her grave or what have you
但是，比如，一些小的，比如，epsilon，你知道，比如，0.0001% 死亡。就像，她处于叠加态，她部分死亡，因为你不知道她现在是活着还是死了。如果你 80 年都不和你祖母说话，假设你足够年轻，可以活 80 年并且仍然在世，那么你祖母……你不知道她是否死了，但她处于一种新的叠加态，她（你知道的）99.999% 死亡，并且（你知道的）一些小的百分比活着，对吧？因为大多数人活不到她会有的岁数，比如 180 岁，对吧？所以极其罕见。一旦你去探望她或她的坟墓，或者其他什么，
then you know immediately and then as patrick said the superposition state collapses and now it's it's either zero or one and so but what the important thing here is that they're sort of like this gradient right so it's like it went from 99 you know uh false zero percent true and then over time it like slowly shifted to to the opposite and so this is what sort of quantum programming is all about is sort of taking advantage of the stochastic nature of various problems to create these superposition states and then hopefully the end goal is to sort of observe these superposition states you know multiple times and then aggregate those results into an answer. So there's a lot of connections between ideas of confidence and probabilities and these kind of things in the quantum world.
那么你就立刻知道了，然后正如 Patrick 所说，叠加态坍缩了，现在它是 0 或 1。所以，但这里重要的事情是，它们有点像这种梯度，对吧？所以它从 99（你知道的）假，0% 真，然后随着时间推移，它慢慢地转向了相反的方向。所以这就是量子编程的全部意义所在，即利用各种问题的随机性来创建这些叠加态，然后希望最终目标是多次观察这些叠加态，然后将这些结果汇总成一个答案。所以量子世界中关于置信度和概率的想法之间有很多联系。
So there's this idea of an actual quantum computer, which is like a current computer we have now, but does all the operations possible in parallel or something like this, right? And you do things really really fast and that's kind of like a general purpose computer but they have now things that are claiming to do quantum computing which is more like along like what jason's saying which is like if you take the traveling salesman problem and you represent the initial you know state of the world then Then you perform in a quantum fashion some set of operations. And then you get to the end. And you have a whole bunch of possible outcomes. But some of them will be optimal.
所以有这种实际量子计算机的想法，它就像我们现在拥有的当前计算机，但并行执行所有可能的操作，或者类似的东西，对吧？你做得非常非常快，这有点像通用计算机。但他们现在有声称可以进行量子计算的东西，这更像……就像 Jason 所说的，比如如果你采用旅行商问题，并且你代表了世界的初始（你知道的）状态，然后你以量子方式执行一组操作。然后你到达终点。你有一大堆可能的结果。但其中一些将是最佳的。
And you want to observe which ones those were by having tried a whole bunch in parallel. And that relies on needing this probability distribution at the end. But if things lost their superposition along the way like something bad happened in the device and a accidental measurement was taken by another particle colliding with the qubit then the operations at the end don't work out right exactly and so you can know that something happened wrong and you won't but you don't know what the right answer would be you just know that something bad happened and um so the important thing about having a qubit which lasted 39 minutes is that like at room temperature is the other thing because typically you keep it
你想通过并行尝试一大堆来观察哪些是最佳的。这依赖于在最后需要这个概率分布。但如果事情在过程中失去了叠加态，比如设备中发生了坏事，并且另一个粒子与量子比特碰撞导致了意外测量，那么最后的操作就不会奏效。对，完全正确。所以你可以知道发生了错误，但你不知道正确答案会是什么，你只知道发生了坏事。而且……所以拥有一个持续 39 分钟的量子比特的重要之处在于，比如在室温下，这是另一件事，因为通常你保持它
really really cold because things move slower and so then i i'm probably butchering this but like no no the way i understand it is like at really cold things move slower right so it's easier to keep things from colliding with the particle but at room temperature you know things are zipping around right and so it's much more likely that a particle will collide with the qubit or something will happen that will cause the position to collapse right exactly I mean so so just to to complete the thought like if something collides with a qubit that means you know where that qubit is that means it's not in a superposition state so yeah you've taken some measurement of it right whether you meant to or not exactly because you could then observe that
非常非常冷，因为东西移动得更慢，所以……我可能把这个搞砸了，但……不，不，我理解的方式是，在非常冷的时候东西移动得更慢，对吧？所以更容易防止东西与粒子碰撞。但在室温下，你知道东西在四处乱窜，对吧？所以粒子与量子比特碰撞的可能性要大得多，或者发生某些事情会导致叠加态坍缩。对，完全正确。我是说，所以……为了完成这个想法，如果某物与量子比特碰撞，这意味着你知道那个量子比特在哪里，这意味着它不在叠加态中。所以是的，你已经对它进行了一些测量，对吧？无论你是否有意为之。完全正确，因为你随后可以观察那个
particle and yeah it's sort of like you know if you ever watch like the world series of poker any of these like any of these like poker you know shows on television and you see sort of the person's chance of winning right and then as soon as they draw a card all of a sudden like it it's it's like it goes from you know 30 70 it's like 99 zero or something right so it's that kind of thing where um if you know as soon as you see that card all all of the dynamics change. And so if you have a card on table and you don't flip it over, now you're exposed to a wide variety of outcomes. These things are all really fascinating and really interesting to me. I wish I had more time to understand it better and explain it better.
粒子，是的，这有点像……你知道，如果你看过世界扑克系列赛或任何这些（你知道的）扑克电视节目，你看到某人获胜的机会，对吧？然后一旦他们抽了一张牌，突然之间……它就像从（你知道的）30/70 变成了 99/0 之类的，对吧？所以就是那种情况，如果……你知道，一旦你看到那张牌，所有的动态都改变了。所以如果你桌上有一张牌，而你不把它翻过来，现在你就暴露在各种各样的结果中。这些事情对我来说都非常迷人，非常有趣。我希望我有更多时间来更好地理解它并更好地解释它。
But yeah, if you're interested, you should go read more about it. Yeah, definitely. Yeah, maybe we should look into this and next book of the show should be Quantum. We should put the onus on ourselves to find some. Or you should go watch every YouTube video about this, and then we can have an actual show, and you can just tell us about it. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
但是的，如果你感兴趣，你应该去读更多关于它的内容。是的，绝对。是的，也许我们应该研究一下这个，节目的下一本书应该是《量子》。我们应该把责任放在自己身上，找一些。或者你应该去观看关于这个的每一个 YouTube 视频，然后我们可以做一个真正的节目，你可以直接告诉我们。是的，是的，完全正确。
Okay. Okay, so last story of the show, Hacking Candy Crush. I thought this was totally awesome. Actually, the title is technically winning at Candy Crush, but it's pretty great. Basically, this guy who... So what is Candy Crush. I thought this was totally awesome. Actually, the title is technically winning at Candy Crush, but it's pretty great. Basically, this guy So what is Candy Crush? Oh yeah, so Candy Crush is an online game that is built
好的。好的，所以节目的最后一个故事，破解《糖果传奇》（Candy Crush）。我觉得这太棒了。实际上，标题在技术上是“在《糖果传奇》中获胜”，但这非常棒。基本上，这个家伙……那么什么是《糖果传奇》？我觉得这太棒了。实际上，标题在技术上是“在《糖果传奇》中获胜”，但这非常棒。基本上，这个家伙……那么什么是《糖果传奇》？哦，是的，所以《糖果传奇》是一款在线游戏，它是用
in Flash, but it uses JSON XML HTTP requests to send data to a server. So, for example, you play this game in Flash, you beat a level, and then it actually packages some information on how that level had progressed and terminated, sends that as a JSON string to the server.
Flash 构建的，但它使用 JSON XML HTTP 请求将数据发送到服务器。所以，例如，你在 Flash 中玩这个游戏，你通关了一个关卡，然后它实际上打包了一些关于该关卡如何进展和终止的信息，将其作为 JSON 字符串发送到服务器。
The server then sort of decides whether to give you a new level or to have you repeat the current level, etc sends that back to you and then etc and more things happen so you know the server actually will send you the content of the levels one at a time so you don't actually have the complete game but yet this person was able to pretend like he beat a level by sending the right JSON to the server, getting the new level content, and then repeating. And it's pretty awesome. Actually, the person's profile picture is just him, like, with his goofy grin. And he just seems like the perfect person to do something like this.
服务器然后决定是给你一个新的关卡，还是让你重复当前的关卡，等等，把它发回给你，然后……等等，更多的事情发生了。所以你知道，服务器实际上会一次一个地发送关卡的内容，所以你实际上并没有完整的游戏。但尽管如此，这个人还是能够通过向服务器发送正确的 JSON，获取新的关卡内容，然后重复，来假装他通关了一个关卡。这太棒了。实际上，这个人的头像就是他自己，带着傻笑。他看起来就是做这种事情的完美人选。
And even if you read further down, the content is great. And the comments, he replies to almost all the comments and it is pretty hilarious actually the whole thread i thought was really amusing so if you want to see how to how to hack online games this is pretty it's pretty epic or how not to design your online game oh yeah that's true yeah um there's this cool thing called encryption i mean but uh but And not trusting clients. Yeah, exactly. Because somebody could write a malicious client.
即使你往下读，内容也很棒。在评论区，他回复了几乎所有的评论，这实际上非常搞笑。整个帖子我觉得非常有趣。所以如果你想看看如何破解在线游戏，这非常……非常史诗，或者说如何不要设计你的在线游戏。哦，是的，那倒是真的。嗯，有一个很酷的东西叫加密，我是说……但……而且不信任客户端。是的，完全正确。因为有人可以编写一个恶意客户端。
That's actually an extremely good point. I mean, for people who are designing any kind of server side apps, you have to expect your client to do. One thing is if you encrypt the string, then usually the decryption algorithm will will just bomb out right um but uh but if you're not doing anything like that yeah you at least want to make sure that the person's doing something sane there was actually a fascinating article i'll see if i can find it um you know for another episode we're all about sort of the
这实际上是一个非常好的观点。我是说，对于那些正在设计任何类型的服务器端应用程序的人来说，你必须预料到你的客户端会做什么。一件事是，如果你加密了字符串，那么通常解密算法会直接崩溃，对吧？嗯……但……但如果你没有做任何类似的事情，是的，你至少要确保那个人在做一些理智的事情。实际上有一篇非常迷人的文章，我会看看能不能找到它……你知道，为了另一期节目，我们都在谈论某种
arms race between uh chinese hackers who were hacking World of Warcraft so that they could get loot and sell it for real money, and the World of Warcraft security team. And really interesting. Basically, they had a rule-based system where if any of the rules fired, they had a human evaluate the activity and then ban the account um then so one of the rules for example was if you uh if you moved more than say you know
中国黑客之间的军备竞赛，他们破解《魔兽世界》以便获得战利品并将其卖成真钱，以及《魔兽世界》安全团队。非常有趣。基本上，他们有一个基于规则的系统，如果任何规则被触发，他们会让一个人评估该活动，然后封禁该账户。嗯……那么，规则之一，例如，是如果你……如果你移动超过，比如，你知道
a thousand strides in less than a second or something like that right then they they fired some rule saying this person's doing something which isn't physically possible in the game right um and these guys got around the rule by they started reverse engineering the rules by after getting so many accounts banned and they'd move 999 units and then wait a second and they wrote had scripts which did that and so i know the whole thing was really interesting i'll see if i can pull it up so this is actually really common this is a whole thing i was reading something similar about when you can like take your you know xbox 360 controller and modify the electrical contacts where the button presses happen to have rapid fire right so everybody's probably seen these like on old consoles you could buy rapid fire game pads yeah instead of when you push the button it just making one electrical connection
一千步在不到一秒钟内，或者类似的事情，对吧？然后他们触发了一些规则，说这个人正在做游戏中物理上不可能的事情，对吧？嗯……而这些人通过他们开始逆向工程这些规则来绕过规则，在被封禁了这么多账户之后，他们会移动 999 个单位，然后等一秒钟。他们编写了脚本来做到这一点。所以我知道整件事非常有趣，我会看看能不能把它找出来。所以这实际上非常普遍，这是一个完整的事情。我读到过类似的东西，关于当你能像拿你的 Xbox 360 手柄并修改按钮按下发生的电气触点以实现连发时，对吧？所以每个人可能都在旧游戏机上见过这些，你可以买连发游戏手柄。是的，而不是当你按下按钮时它只产生一个电气连接。
it would sit there and make it break it make it break it make it break it and give you rapid fire but that you could use that to cheat in some games and so they actually like tried to detect on the server side for online play for local play they don't really care but for like online play and you know people gaming the system to get better rankings they tried to do things like detect the distance between key presses, the time between key presses. There we go. And so if you're pressing too regularly and fast, then they know you must be cheating, right?
它会一直按，让它断开，让它断开，让它断开，从而实现连发，但你可以利用这一点在某些游戏中作弊，所以他们实际上尝试在服务器端进行检测以用于在线游戏，对于本地游戏他们并不太在意，但对于在线游戏，你知道，人们为了获得更好的排名而操纵系统，他们尝试做一些事情，比如检测按键之间的距离，按键之间的时间间隔。就是这样。所以如果你按得太有规律且太快，那么他们就知道你一定在作弊，对吧？
And so then they can ban you. So then the people who did these illegal mods to the controllers had to embed little microcontrollers, which would vary the timing so that it looked human enough and be just fast enough that it was helpful but not too fast that you would get caught gotcha that's so yeah some gaussian noise or something to the to the clicks so that they weren't all but it's crazy that people would spend time doing this right like making microcontrollers and then selling them and i i wonder if it's profitable. I have no idea.
然后他们就可以封禁你。所以那些对控制器进行非法改装的人不得不嵌入微控制器，这些微控制器会改变时间间隔，使其看起来足够像人类的操作，并且速度刚好快到有帮助，但又不会快到被抓到。原来如此，所以他们会在点击中加入一些高斯噪声之类的东西，这样它们就不会显得那么机械。但人们花时间做这种事真的很疯狂，对吧？比如制作微控制器然后出售它们，我不知道这是否有利可图。我一点头绪也没有。
Yeah, who knows? I mean, I remember at one point I had a mouse where you could hit the button. There's a button you get on the mouse that would make the scroll wheel have no friction. And you could just spin indefinitely and it would just keep spinning. So I used this button and then I bound the mouse wheel to like firing a pistol in Counter-Strike.
是啊，谁知道呢？我的意思是，我记得有一次我有一个鼠标，你可以按下一个按钮。鼠标上有一个按钮可以让滚轮失去摩擦力。你可以让它无限旋转，它就会一直转下去。所以我用了这个按钮，然后把鼠标滚轮绑定到《反恐精英》里开枪的操作上。
And that was pretty fun. But I mean, that was a long time ago. I bet you get banned for that now. All right. So enough about hacking video games. So now we're doing the book of the show. My book of the show is mahout in action which is uh you know there's many of these in action series uh of books um mahout we i believe we talked about it in the machine learning
那还挺有趣的。但我的意思是，那是很久以前的事了。我敢打赌你现在这么做会被封号。好了，关于黑客攻击电子游戏的话题就到此为止。现在我们进入本期书单环节。我推荐的书是《Mahout实战》(Mahout in Action)，你知道，“实战”系列有很多书，Mahout，我相信我们在机器学习播客里讨论过它。
one of the machine learning podcasts but mahout is a uh machine learning suite of algorithms some of them run on Hadoop, which is, as we talked about, like a MapReduce framework. Some of them actually just are meant to run on a single machine. So if you just have, you know, a machine sitting around or, you know, you want to do some coding, you can actually use the algorithms in Mahoot without having to set up, you know, a bunch of nodes, a bunch of clusters, a bunch of clusters
在其中一期机器学习播客里提到过，但Mahout是一套机器学习算法，其中一些运行在Hadoop上，正如我们所讨论的，它是一个MapReduce框架。其中一些实际上只是为了在单台机器上运行。所以如果你手头有一台机器，或者你想写点代码，你实际上可以使用Mahout中的算法，而不必配置一堆节点、一堆集群。
or anything kind of complicated. So I've recently using this a lot. It's pretty awesome. It has a bit of a learning curve. Mahout does, which is why this book is so great. It actually walks you through how to use many of the algorithms in Mahout. And I feel like it's a pretty good read. I'm not all the way through yet
或者任何复杂的东西。所以我最近经常使用它。它非常棒。Mahout的学习曲线有点陡峭，这就是为什么这本书这么好。它实际上引导你如何使用Mahout中的许多算法。我觉得这是一本很不错的书。我还没完全读完。
but i'm pretty happy with what i've read so wait so you're recommending a book and you don't know the ending yeah i have a feeling it ends with uh in the appendix that's oh spoiler what if it's a cliffhanger check out our book two actually i found I found out. There's a microtransaction at the end of the book. You can't read the last chapter until you pay $5 more. You know, they actually have that. It's kind of sad. But my wife was reading a free book from the Play Store. And sure enough, a few chapters in, it was like, oh, why don't you do an in-app or, you know, in-book transaction to get the rest of the book? I was like, that sucks. Oh, that's, oh, that's pretty devastating.
但我对目前读到的内容很满意。等等，所以你在推荐一本书，但你不知道结局？是啊，我有种预感它会在附录里结束。哦，剧透了。如果它是悬念结局怎么办？看看我们的第二本书。其实我发现了，书的结尾有一个微交易。你必须再付5美元才能读最后一章。你知道，他们真的有这种东西。这有点可悲。但我妻子在Play商店读一本免费书时，果然，读了几章之后，它就提示说，哦，为什么不进行应用内或书内交易来获取剩下的部分呢？我说，那太烂了。哦，那真是太令人沮丧了。
I mean, they should at least tell you. Maybe they did. Yeah, yeah. If they're upfront about it, it's like, oh, you know, this book isn't free, but we give you the first three chapters for free. Yeah, they might have said that, but it's, you know, in that small text that nobody ever reads. Oh, okay. Or at least, at least your wife doesn't read. Yeah, exactly might have said that, but it's, you know, in that small text that nobody ever reads. Oh, okay. Or at least your wife doesn't read. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Oh, all right.
我的意思是，他们至少应该告诉你。也许他们说了。是啊，是啊。如果他们提前说明，就像是，哦，你知道，这本书不是免费的，但我们免费提供前三章。是啊，他们可能说了，但你知道，是在没人会读的小字里。哦，好吧。或者至少你妻子没读。是啊，完全正确。可能说了，但你知道，是在没人会读的小字里。哦，好吧。或者至少你妻子没读。是啊，完全正确。是啊。哦，好吧。
So my book is Bebop to the Boolean Boogie. That sounds awesome. And if you could say that five times fast, I will give you a thumbs up. So this is in theme with our episode topic topic and it was a book i read actually many years ago i think i might have found at the library i'm not sure where i found it at and it was when i before i had taken up much programming and it describes just like it's saying well it doesn't actually say but boolean boogie is talking about a lot about boolean logic and specifically about boolean logic in reference to how it would be used in circuits.
所以我的书是《从波普到布尔布吉》(Bebop to the Boolean Boogie)。听起来很棒。如果你能快速说五遍，我就给你点个赞。这与我们这期节目的主题相呼应，这是我多年前读过的一本书，我想我可能是在图书馆找到的，我不确定是在哪找到的，那是在我还没开始深入编程之前，它描述的内容就像书名所暗示的那样，虽然它并没有直接说，但“布尔布吉”谈论了很多关于布尔逻辑的内容，特别是关于布尔逻辑在电路中是如何使用的。
Oh, wait. So this isn't like a fiction sci-fi book or something? No. Oh, okay. Sorry. I have a legitimate, actual, useful book this time. No, no. It's not a dig on you.
哦，等等。所以这不是一本科幻小说之类的书？不是。哦，好吧。抱歉。我这次有一本合法的、实际的、有用的书。不，不。我不是在挖苦你。
I saw the title, and I just thought, for sure, this was a sci-fi book. So why it attracted to me when I guess I was in probably middle school or early high school was that, yeah, so it's a really fun approach. So similar to the recommendation of the Design Patterns book, Head First Design Patterns, it takes a somewhat lighthearted approach to design patterns. But it is a serious learning. It's just like you do learn the design patterns that they go over. This is very similar. It takes a lighthearted approach. Yeah, it uh really good reviews on uh on amazon a couple other websites so yeah okay awesome i'll definitely yeah it actually got a perfect five stars with with uh on amazon so yeah that's pretty awesome so i haven't i i'm vaguely remembering it from
我看到书名时，还以为这肯定是一本科幻书。所以它吸引我的时候，大概是在我上初中或高中早期，它确实是一种非常有趣的切入点。所以类似于《设计模式》那本书的推荐，《Head First设计模式》，它对设计模式采取了一种比较轻松的方法。但它是严肃的学习。你确实学到了他们所讲的设计模式。这本书非常相似。它采取了一种轻松的方法。是啊，它在亚马逊和其他几个网站上评价非常好，所以是的，好吧，太棒了，我一定会读的。它在亚马逊上确实获得了完美的五星评价，所以是的，这太棒了，所以我对它有点模糊的记忆。
a long time ago and there's this cover isn't the cover that I remember seeing. So I'm sure there's a new edition now or something. Um, but yeah, so it goes over like if you're new to programming, especially it could be helpful or if you're interested in, um, so a lot of people talk about like circuits and electronics and electrical
很久以前的事了，而且现在的封面和我记忆中的不一样。所以我肯定现在有新版本之类的。嗯，所以它涵盖了如果你是编程新手，它会特别有帮助，或者如果你对电路、电子和电气工程感兴趣。
engineering. Um, and so there's analog stuff and digital stuff and to do any, you know, digital stuff, you are going to get into kind of Boolean logic and learning about that kind digital stuff. And to do any digital stuff, you are going to get into kind of Boolean logic and learning about that kind of stuff. And we'll go over that.
嗯，所以有模拟电路和数字电路，要做任何数字电路的东西，你都会接触到布尔逻辑并学习那种数字电路的东西。要做任何数字电路的东西，你都会接触到布尔逻辑并学习那种东西。我们会讲到这些。
Like what is an AND gate and how does it function? What is an OR gate? How does it function? What about exclusive OR? How do you count in binary? How do you do binary math at like a gate level? How do you do like, how do you call them cardinal maps or whatever like
比如什么是与门，它是如何工作的？什么是或门？它是如何工作的？异或门呢？你怎么用二进制计数？你怎么在门级进行二进制数学运算？你怎么称呼它们，卡诺图之类的。
optimizing if you what's called a truth table so like you have inputs that are either zero or one and you have many of them and here's the output you want for each set of inputs how would you devise a set of gates to do that um and so this will come into play we'll talk about this maybe more in a little bit level and a little bit later uh and in the episode but uh this book goes over that and it does it in a light-hearted and fun way that uh i remember being fond of when i was younger not that you have to be young to read it i'm sure it's equally fun now and i should bring it back out and uh read it again but that's my recommendation cool cool yeah it awesome. I'll give it a go. All right. Tool of the show. Tool of the show.
优化所谓的真值表，比如你有输入，要么是0要么是1，你有很多输入，这是你想要的每个输入集的输出，你会如何设计一组门来实现它？嗯，所以这会派上用场，我们稍后在节目中可能会更多地谈论这一点，但这本书涵盖了这些内容，而且它以一种轻松有趣的方式进行，我记得我年轻时很喜欢它，并不是说你必须年轻才能读它，我相信它现在依然同样有趣，我应该把它找出来再读一遍，但这就是我的推荐。酷，酷，是的，太棒了。我会试一试。好了。本期工具环节。本期工具环节。
So my tool of the show is actually a website. It's Kaggle, K-A-G-G-L-E. And it's pretty amazing. So basically, so Kaggle is a data science competition website. And so it's funny. A lot of people don't really know what a data scientist is or what that even means. I mean, they think it's someone like a lab coat who mixes data from one vial to another. And so this is pretty interesting. The site has a handful of competitions that are fake competitions meant to sort of teach you about data science, which I think is extremely extraordinary because it really sort of helps you understand that it's not about programming in a certain language or something like that.
所以我的本期工具是一个网站。它是Kaggle，K-A-G-G-L-E。它非常神奇。所以基本上，Kaggle是一个数据科学竞赛网站。这很有趣。很多人并不真正知道什么是数据科学家，或者那意味着什么。我的意思是，他们认为那是像穿着白大褂的人，把数据从一个试管倒到另一个试管里。所以这很有趣。这个网站有一些虚构的竞赛，旨在教你关于数据科学的知识，我认为这非常了不起，因为它确实帮助你理解，这不仅仅是关于用某种语言编程之类的事情。
It really sort of tells you sort of it gives you a list of sort of data science problems and then walks you through several solutions, which is pretty great. Now, they also have serious competitions with real rewards. And the way it works is they provide you with a data set. So there's a competition going on right now where they provide you with a bunch of data from Stack Exchange. So Stack Exchange is the sort of mothership for Stack Overflow, Math Exchange, and all these other websites where you can ask questions, right? So people generally tag their questions. So you might ask a question like, oh, I keep getting this Java runtime exception. And then you tag the question Java so that people looking to answer questions will be able to do filtering, right?
它确实列出了一系列数据科学问题，然后引导你完成几个解决方案，这非常棒。现在，他们也有带有真实奖励的严肃竞赛。它的工作方式是他们为你提供一个数据集。所以现在有一个竞赛，他们提供了来自Stack Exchange的一堆数据。所以Stack Exchange是Stack Overflow、Math Exchange以及所有其他你可以提问的网站的母舰，对吧？所以人们通常会给他们的问题打标签。所以你可能会问一个问题，比如，哦，我一直收到这个Java运行时异常。然后你给问题打上Java标签，这样寻找答案的人就能进行过滤，对吧？
So Kaggle has a competition where they give you a bunch of questions with the tags. And then they give you another set called the test set of questions, but you don't know what the tags are um so you are supposed to produce the tags for that test set and then um send your your uh um your predicted tags to them to their server and they will score them and give you a score back and the goal is to to get the highest score um so all of these have a deadline each of these competitions and the scores are pretty awesome like here's one flight one thing too about these competitions
所以Kaggle有一个竞赛，他们给你一堆带有标签的问题。然后他们给你另一组称为测试集的问题，但你不知道标签是什么，所以你应该为该测试集生成标签，然后将你的预测标签发送给他们的服务器，他们会给它们评分并给你一个分数，目标是获得最高分。所以所有这些竞赛都有截止日期，分数非常棒，比如这里有一个。关于这些竞赛有一点。
I don't know for a fact but I believe pretty strongly that the people that are posting these competitions have like a vested interest in the algorithms well considering the reward for this one's like let's just say $200,000 I'm pretty sure somebody has a vested interest in it yeah so so general electric i
我不知道事实是否如此，但我非常确信发布这些竞赛的人对这些算法有既得利益。嗯，考虑到这个奖金是20万美元，我敢肯定有人对此有既得利益。是啊，所以通用电气，我猜这就是发布者，对吧？他们为能在未来30天内尽可能完整地解决这个数据集的人提供22万美元。这确实非常了不起。大多数奖励都相当小。实际上，Facebook有一个竞赛，奖励据说是Facebook的一份工作。嗯，我认为这非常有趣。但是，你知道，大多数时候奖励是5000美元之类的。那些奖励是知识的竞赛，那是一种特殊情况。这意味着这些竞赛旨在教你数据科学。
guess that's who this is right they are offering 220 000 for somebody who can um solve this data set as completely as possible over the next 30 days um that's actually pretty extraordinary most of the most of the rewards are, are pretty small. Actually, Facebook has a competition and the reward is allegedly a job at Facebook. Um, which is, I think, pretty interesting. But, uh, you know, most of the time the rewards are, you know, $5,000 or something. The ones where the rewards are knowledge, that's sort of a special case. That means these are ones that are meant to teach you data science
以及如何成为一名数据科学家。不错。嗯，那么像GE这个或者其他什么的是不是这样？我没读过，但像Netflix奖那样，他们是否要求在颁发奖金之前达到一定的嵌入阈值，或者在这一时期结束时有人会获得奖金？是啊，这是一个很好的观点。所以如果你查看任何这些竞赛的排行榜，他们实际上在排行榜上有一些特殊的位置，标示出了一些里程碑，他们期望。
and how to be a data scientist nice um so is it the case that like this ge1 or whatever i didn't read it but like is it the case some of these like they require like what was that the netflix prize was a while back like they require a certain threshold of embeddement to be reached before they award a prize or somebody will get the prize at the end of this time period. Yeah, that's a really good point. So if you look at the leaderboard for any of these competitions, they actually have some special spots on the leaderboard which denote sort of milestones and they expect
所有这些里程碑都能完成。比如，看看GE那个，他们有一个样本提交基准。我想如果你做得没有基准好，那么你就不会获得奖励。比如，Stack Exchange，他们的基准是，他们挑选四个最受欢迎的标签。
all of those milestones to be completed. Like, for example, looking at the GE one, they had a sample submission benchmark. And I guess you have to do, if you don't do better than the benchmark, then you won't get an award. Like, for example, the Stack Exchange, their benchmark is, they pick the four most popular tags
看看它是否是其中之一。如果你不能做得比那更好，那么，你知道，如果没人能做得比那更好，那么就没人能拿到奖金。啊，好吧。但从我目前看到的竞赛来看，每一个竞赛都有人获胜。
and see if it's any one of those. And if you can't do better than that, then they, you know, if no one can do better than that, then no one gets a prize. Ah, okay. But from the competitions that I've seen thus far, everyone, every one of the competitions has been won by somebody.
好的。所以，是的，这非常有趣。我的意思是，我不知道它有多大的竞争性。每当你遇到像这样涉及整个互联网的事情时，你必须预料到你会遇到最优秀、最聪明的人。所以，你知道，虽然他们提供了这22万美元，但我不会指望去赢它或者想去赢它，我敢肯定有大批的人在为此工作，但能参与其中或参与任何这些竞赛并获得一些好的结果，测试你的系统，这仍然非常酷。如果什么都没有，这至少是更多的数据供你测试你的系统。
Okay. So, yeah, it's pretty interesting. I mean, I don't know sort of how competitive it is um anytime you have something like this with the whole internet involved um you have to expect that you'll get the best and the brightest and so um you know although they're offering this 220 000 dollars uh i wouldn't go in there expecting to win it or wanting to win it i'm sure there's like whole armies of people are working on but it's still phenomenally cool to work on this and or on any of these and get some good results and test your if nothing else it's more data for you to test your system on you
你知道，测试你的系统，学习这些技术，而且我敢肯定，即使人们不知道这个网站是什么，当你去求职或换工作时，你知道，它会让你非常自信地谈论事情，你可以向人们指出，比如，哦，这是我做过的事情，比如我做了这些类型的分析。是啊，完全正确，完全正确。嗯，每个竞赛都有一个论坛，你可以在论坛上发帖、回答问题、提问等等。
know well test your system on learn these techniques and like i'm sure this kind of thing is even if people don't know what this site is when you go for a job or to change jobs that you know it'll let you talk about things very confidently and you can point people to like oh here's stuff i did like i did these type of analyses yeah exactly exactly um i do there's also a forum for each of these competitions and you can post you can answer questions ask questions etc on the
而且是的，我认为这非常有趣，我绝对推荐每个人去看看。太棒了，Facebook招聘竞赛还有34天结束。所以当你听到这个的时候，剩下的时间就不多了。是啊。
forum and yeah I think it's phenomenally interesting I definitely recommend everyone check it out that's awesome there's 34 days to go on the Facebook recruiting competition. So by the time you hear this, you're not going to have much left. Yeah.
不，我开玩笑的。是啊，所以这些竞赛其实非常有趣。Yandex，我相信是俄罗斯的搜索引擎，提供9000美元，奖励给那些能根据用户的个人偏好更好地进行排名的人。我不知道。我认为这些东西真的很有趣。而且数据就在那里供你访问，这非常酷。通常你必须去抓取维基百科或做一些痛苦的事情才能获得数据。但这里有一堆非常棒的数据，正等着被下载。酷。是啊，绝对。所以现在我们进入FPGA环节。
No, I'm just kidding. Yeah, so these competitions are actually pretty interesting. Yandex, which I believe is the Russian search engine, is offering $9,000 to somehow do a better job ranking given the personal preferences of the users. I don't know. I think this stuff is really interesting. And it's pretty cool that the data is right there
等等，我们跳过了我的本周工具？好吧。哦，天哪，我很抱歉。你知道吗？它们都以K开头，我想我只是，我不知道，我的眼睛跳过了它。没关系。所以我的本周工具是KiCad，或者KiCad。我不知道你怎么发音。
for you to access. Usually you have to go scraping Wikipedia or doing something painful to get data. But here's just a bunch of really awesome data just waiting to be downloaded. Cool. Yeah, definitely. So now we're on to FPGAs.
它，K-I-C-A-D，好的，这是一个工具，再次与节目主题相呼应，多么贴切的押韵，是一个用于设计电路和构建PCB（印刷电路板）的工具。所以如果你要制作自己的电路，如果你参与任何类型的硬件、微处理器相关的东西，你最终会想做这件事。这是一个开源工具，免费，没有限制，让你能够布局，我想有一个电阻器，我想有一个处理器芯片，我想有这些输入和输出，把它们放上去，排列它们，连接它们，然后构建一个代表该原理图的电路板。而这通常是由非常昂贵的软件完成的。
Wait, we're skipping my tool of the week? Okay. Oh, man, I'm so sorry. You know what? They both started with K, and I think I just, I don't know, my eyes just skipped it. It's okay. So my tool of the week is KiCad, or KiCad. I don't know how you pronounce
所以很多人使用这个叫Eagle的工具，或者还有另一个，我想叫Altium。但这些非常昂贵，要花费数千美元才能拥有这些电路板。人们用这些来构建像你电脑里的主板，比如，哦，我需要内存插槽，一个处理器插槽，你知道，我需要这边的这些端口，还有这个北桥，就像所有这些东西都被布局好，并且可能有四层不同平面的电路铜箔，在构成你主板的单块电路板中，或者六层，我甚至不知道主板里有多少层。好的，但我不想学习任何那些东西，那听起来太复杂了。但我一直在做一些项目，比如用Arduino，我们之前谈过Arduino，
it k-i-c-a-d okay and this is a tool again in theme with the show how apropos that rhymed um is a tool for designing uh electrical circuits and building pcbs printed circuit boards um so if you're gonna make your own circuit which if you get involved in any kind of hardware microprocessor stuff you'll eventually kind of want to do this is an open source tool that's free no limitations and lets you kind of lay out i want to have a resistor and i want to have this processor chip and i want to have these inputs and outputs and plop them down arrange them connect them up and then build a board that would represent that schematic. And that's something that's normally done by very expensive
树莓派，你想把东西连接在一起，你不想使用小电线，你可以使用像这样的工具，要么制作你自己的印刷电路板，这是我实际上想在某个时候尝试做的事情，要么把它发送给一家公司。所以我实际上在我有一个RGB LED之前做过这个，它是一个LED设备，但它内部嵌入了三个LED，一个红色，一个绿色，一个蓝色，所以你可以把它做成任何你想要的颜色。嗯，我打印，我制作了一个小电路板，大约一平方英寸或更小，并连接引脚，这样你就可以把它插在面包板上，连接到LED的引脚上，这些引脚在面包板上不太合适。所以我就能在工具中设计它，把它寄给一家公司，他们把它寄回给我，我的小PCB，我得到了大约三个，来自这个地方。那花了多少钱？大约三美元。
software. So a lot of people use this tool called like Eagle, or there's another one, I think it's called Altium. But these are like very expensive, like thousands of dollars to have these boards. And people use these to build like the motherboard in your computer right so like oh i need slots for ram and a slot for this processor and you know i need these ports over here and this north bridge it's like all those things get laid out and may have like you know four layers of different planes of circuit copper um in the single board that is your motherboard or six or I don't even know how many are in a motherboard okay but I don't want to learn any of that that sounds way too complicated but I have been doing some projects like with an Arduino we've talked about Arduino before a
哇，所以你基本上可以制作一个单板计算机，做一些相对简单的事情，只要20美元左右。所以这取决于，它是基于你需要电路板的大小，你需要多少层，它会变得非常复杂。但如果你不知道这个工具，它很酷，你应该看看。这个是开源的，所以你不会遇到尺寸限制，所以其他一些工具是有限制的，比如你不能超过3英寸乘2英寸，如果你超过了，那么你就得付费。但如果你设计的是简单的东西，并且只有一面，你可能想制作一些实际上相当大的东西，你可以自己做，而你不能选择那个工具。
Raspberry Pi and you want to like connect things together and you don't want to have to use little wires you could use a tool like this and either make your own printed circuit board which is something i actually want to try to do sometime or send it to a company so i actually did this before i had an rgb led that so it's one led device but it has three leds embedded inside of it one red one green one blue so you can make it any color you want um and i print i made a little circuit board that's like an inch square or less um and connects pins so you can plug it on a breadboard to the pins of the led which didn't fit on a breadboard well um and so i was able to design that in the tool and get it ship it off to a company and they sent it back to me my little pcbs and i got like three of them um from this place and how much did that cost it's like three dollars
所以当我自学这些东西时，我想在一个我永远不必担心遇到某种限制并感到难过的地方做，因为我不会花数千美元去买那个工具。是啊，对，绝对。这超级有趣。实际上，我喜欢这些Olo统计数据。它们在许多不同的开源网站上都有，但它说KiCad中有585,000行代码。所以我不知道那在做什么，但它在做，那里有很多努力。所以有很多关于放置的东西。
wow so you can basically you can make you can make like a single board computer that does something relatively simple for you know 20 bucks or something so it depends like it's based on the size of the board you need how many layers you need it gets complicated really fast but if you don't know about this tool it's cool you should check it out this one's open source and so you don't run into limitation of size so some of the other ones are limited like you can't go bigger than three inches by two inches and if you do then like you'd have to pay but if you're designing something simple and only having like one surface you might want to make something actually pretty big that you could do yourself and you couldn't
自动布线小电路路径之类的东西，这很酷，你应该看看。嗯，实际上最近CERN（欧洲核子研究中心）参与了这个项目，他们想用它来进行许多电路设计，所以他们开始为这个项目做出贡献。哦，非常非常酷。这超级有趣。是啊，去看看吧。你怎么处理，比如，我注意到这里的图片上，它有一个物理开关和一个物理串口，
choose that tool so when i've been teaching my stuff myself this stuff i wanted to do it on something where i wouldn't ever have to worry about running into some limitation and feeling bad because i'm not going to spend thousands of dollars to buy the tool. Yeah, right, definitely. This is super interesting. It's actually, I love these Olo stats. They're on many different open source sites, but it says that it's 585,000 lines of code in KiCad. So I don't know what that's doing, but it's doing, there's a lot of effort there. So there's a lot of things around like place
比如串口，你知道，串口输出。你怎么，我的意思是，你发送原理图的公司，他们也做开关部分和所有东西吗？不，所以通常你提前决定，比如我想要一个开关，然后有常见的开关，或者他们可能在库里有它，或者你可以根据你挑选的开关的数据表自己指定它。
automatically routing the little electrical paths and stuff like that it's pretty cool you should check it out um and actually uh recently cern um got involved with the project and they want to use it for doing a lot of their circuit designs and so they're starting to contribute to the project oh very very cool this is super interesting. Yeah, check it out. How do you deal with like, so I noticed on the picture here, it has like a physical switch and a physical serial,
然后当你拿回它时，有公司会为你填充电路板，比如继续焊接所有东西，但这通常要贵得多。我甚至，我从来没研究过那个。但基本上我做的是，哦，我已经有这些常见的零件了，我已经制作了一些示例电路，我只是想把它放在一个电路板上，所以你自己焊接它。所以你知道，提前知道，比如我有这个开关，你把它放上去。所以你从你用来寻找超人尸体的核潜艇上拿走一些零件，用它来构建你的下一个项目。我会说是的，我不知道你刚才说了什么。但是的，如果你对硬件感兴趣，去看看吧，它很酷。你可能已经知道了，如果你不知道，而且它引起了你的兴趣，或者我说的东西引起了你的兴趣，你应该研究一下。关于这个还有一件事，然后我就放过你，但你去哪里买像开关这样非常基本的东西？比如，电机，你怎么得到那些东西？是啊，互联网当然是一个答案。所以大多数电子产品，是的，这其实有点困难。所以有几个地方，比如你会了解到这些地方，DigiKey、Mouser、Element 14，就像有不同的地方你会了解到，也许我们可以在另一期节目中更多地谈论这个，因为它实际上非常迷人。我现在非常沉迷于此。但是的，比如有这样的网站，但它们
like serial, you know, serial out. How do you, I mean, the company that you send the schematic to, do they also, do they do the switch part too and everything? No, so typically you decide in advance like i want a switch and then there's like common switches or they may have it in a library or you may you know specify it yourself based on the data shade of the switch
服务于那些真正以此为生的人，对吧？比如制造主板或制造进入汽车或电视的电子产品，任何东西。对。所以他们正在为他们获取零件。他们只是字面上，如果你搜索像电阻器这样的东西，他们会有上百万种不同的电阻器。
that you've picked out and then when you get it back there are companies which will populate the board for you like go ahead and solder everything on but that's typically much more expensive i don't even i've never even looked into that but basically what i do is like oh i have these common parts already around and i've made some example circuit and i just want to put it on a you know board and so you solder it on yourself so you know in advance like i have this switch and you drop it on so you take a few of the parts from your nuclear submarine that you use to hunt for superman's body and use that to build your next project i'm gonna say yes i don't know what you just said um but yeah check it out if you're into hardware it's pretty cool you probably already know about it and if you don't uh and it strikes
那真的让人不知所措。所以还有其他地方，比如SparkFun，更面向业余爱好者，他们有最常见的零件。比如我们知道你可能想要这个。比如这是最基本的开关，如果你只需要一个开关，就选这个开关。所以你可以去SparkFun，找到一些东西，然后去DigiKey完成收集之类的。是啊，比如如果他们没有某些东西，然后你也可以去，有当地的电子商店。所以这里有一个地方，我特别去过加利福尼亚湾区，那里有他们所谓的剩余电子产品。所以公司倒闭了，或者有旧设备，他们把它卖给这个地方，然后他们允许你进去。
your interest or the things i said pique your interest uh you should look into it one more thing on this and then i'll let you off the hook but where do you go to buy the uh things like like switches like very basic things like this like so okay motors how do you get any of that yeah so the internet of course that's one answer so most of the electronics yeah so it's actually kind of difficult so there's a couple like you'll learn about like these places digikey mauser uh element 14 like there's like different places you'll learn about and maybe we can talk more about this in another episode because it's actually really fascinating i'm really into this presently um but yeah so like there's websites like that but they
你可以买到非常便宜的东西，他们只是有成箱成箱的电阻器和，你知道，各种电容器。是啊，去那里真的很棒。哦，天哪，我们得去。好的，你，它是对婴儿安全的吗？如果我们抱着婴儿的话。不，不，你会伸手去触电之类的。嗯，不是触电，而是吞下，那是成吨的微小组件，对吧？哦，是的。好吧，我们得找时间做这件事。这听起来很史诗。好的。它确实很酷。它很有趣。所以无论如何，进入FPGA环节。是啊，FPGA。所以我实际上，我想我知道。
serve like people who are literally doing this for a job, right? Like building motherboards or building the electronics that go into cars or just TVs, anything. Right. And so they're getting parts for them. And they just literally, if you search for like a resistor, they'll have a million different kinds of resistors.
所以当然，你知道，只是背景。我几乎完全做了理论计算机科学。帕特里克主修计算机工程。因此，当涉及到任何这些东西时，我是一个彻底的卢德分子，但我知道一些事情，我会尽力跟上。所以FPGA是可编程门阵列。F是什么？现场。哦，是的，现场可编程门阵列。嗯，我会让你从那里开始。这将是一个有趣的话题，我们会谈论一点编程，因为编程FPGA有点有趣和不同，但也只是关于FPGA如何与处理器交互。所以如果你曾经做任何所谓的嵌入式系统编程，
That's really overwhelming. So then there are other places like spark fund that are more hobbyist oriented where they have the most common ones. Like we know you'll probably want this. Like this is most basic switch if you just need a switch just choose this switch so you could go to spark fun like find a few things and then go to digi key to like complete the collection or something yeah like if they didn't have something and then you can also go there's local electronic stores so there's like a place here specifically that i've gone to in the bay area of california that has like what they call surplus electronics so companies go out of business or um there's like old equipment and they sell it to this place and then they allow you to come in
你经常处理FPGA，或者可以在公司处理FPGA。所以它们非常常见，在许多商业应用中，或者只是取决于你试图做什么，你可能会遇到它，知道它是很好的，因为你会看到它，人们在谈论它。如果你做任何非理论或仅高级应用编程。所以一点历史是，我们谈论了一点，当我们谈论本期书单关于布尔逻辑和与门和或门时，这些东西代表了当你有一个1和一个0时，你想说，如果且仅如果两者都为真，我想要输出为真吗？所以你有那个布尔
and you can buy stuff really cheap and they just have like bins and bins of resistors and you know various capacitors yeah it's actually awesome to go to it oh my gosh we gotta go okay are you uh is it is it baby safe like if we were holding the baby no no you would reach out and electrocute himself or something well not electrocute but like swallow it's tons of tiny components right oh yeah all right we'll have to find some time to do this. This sounds pretty epic. Okay. It is pretty cool. It's a lot of fun. So anyways, so on to FPGAs. Yeah, FPGAs. So I actually, I think I know.
逻辑，你可以使用布尔逻辑来描述，你知道，不断增长的复杂组件。所以只需几个与门和或门，你就可以描述一个叫多路复用器的东西。多路复用器说，比如我有五条不同的输入线，我想指定其中哪五条被放到输出上。或者我有两个数字和两个所谓的寄存器，一点点内存，我想把它们加在一起。所以你只需几个与门和或门就可以指定这一点。一旦你定义了所有这些组件，你就可以把这些组件加在一起，实际上构建CPU。所以这就是处理器是如何构建的，是从这些数字门的集合中构建的。事实上，有几个门可以用来制造所有其他门。
So of course, you know, just some background. I did almost entirely theoretical computer science. And Patrick majored in computer engineering. And as a result, I am a complete Luddite when it comes to any of this but i know a few things i will try my best to keep up uh so fpga is uh programmable gate array what's the f field oh yeah field programmable gate array and um i'll let you take it from there so this is going to be an interesting topic we'll talk a little bit about programming because um programming fpgas is is kind of interesting and different but also just about like how fpgas may interact with processors so if you're ever doing any what's called embedded systems programming
所以只需一种类型的门，你实际上就可以构建整个CPU。如果你曾经上过任何相关课程或跟随任何关于此的教程，它实际上非常有益。我在学校时做的一件事是从那些与门和或门开始，实际上构建了一个完整的，我想我们制作了一个4位处理器。你实际上有内存和指令集，你必须学习什么是汇编编程，还有一个小开关，你在时钟上，就像你会上下拨动开关，实际上给CPU计时，所以它就像一个1赫兹的4位处理器。嗯，课程实验部分的期末考试实际上是实验助教带进一块内存，
you often um deal with fpgas or can deal with fpgas at a company so it's they're very common um in a lot of commercial applications or um just depending on what you're trying to do you you may come across it and it's good to know because you'll see it out there and people talking about it uh if you're doing any non-theoretical or only high level application programming so so a little bit of history is that um so we talked a little bit, and when we were talking about the book of the show about Boolean logic and AND gates and OR gates, and these are the things which kind of represent when you have like a one and a zero, and you want to say, if only if both of them are true, do I want the output to be true? And so you have that Boolean
在一个芯片上，把它插进你构建的CPU里，你会坐在那里给它计时，你会用LED代表输出。他会写下时钟点击10次后，LED是什么，20次后，30次后。然后它们必须是正确的，你才能通过，它代表了指令实际上被执行，结果被显示。嗯，你根本不知道他的指令集里有什么，因为他们给了你，但你不知道他在你的处理器上运行了什么特定的程序。哦，我明白了。所以是的，我的意思是，从，如果我错了请纠正我，我认为为什么
logic and you can use Boolean logic to describe, you know, ever growing complicated components. So with just a few AND and OR gates, you can describe a thing called a multiplexer. And a multiplexer says like I have five different input lines and I want to specify which of those five get put onto the output. Or I have two numbers and two what's called registers, little bits of memory, and I want to add them together. So you can specify that with just a handful of AND and OR gates. And once you have all of those components defined, you can add those components together and actually build CPUs. So that's how a processor gets built is from a collection of these digital gates. And in fact, there are a couple gates that can be used to make all other gates.
你知道一个人会想要编程他们自己的FPGA，是因为当你只使用普通处理器工作时，你是串行地做事情，处理器可以做任何你知道你想做的事情，它可以做乘法、加法、除法，你知道许多其他操作。但它是为了做任何这些事情而设计的，它并没有真正向某一方面倾斜，或者我猜它是平衡的，它没有向某一方面偏向。所以如果你需要做40个加法操作，它们都会一个接一个地排队。现在，处理器会尝试做乱序执行，你知道处理器已经变得非常复杂，但现实是，你需要一次添加整个数字数组，这就是你的程序设计的方式，或者你想创建的算法。
So with only a single type of gate, you could actually build an entire CPU. And if you ever take any classes of it or follow any tutorials about this, it is actually really rewarding. One of the things I did when I was in school is start from those ANDs and OR gates and actually build up to a whole, I think we made a four-bit processor. And you actually had memory and an instruction set, and you had had memory and an instruction set and you had to learn like what assembly programming really is about and a little switch that you were at the clock like you would switch the switch up and down and actually clock the cpu so it was like a one hertz four-bit processor um and the final exam for the lab part of the class was actually the TA for the lab would bring in a piece of memory
它的设计，那么用FPGA，你可以字面上拥有八个加法副本，你知道，机械装置都在同一时间运行。是啊。所以这真是一个好主意。所以比如如果你有一个32位处理器，你想把两个64位数字加在一起，对吧？所以那里的32位处理器意味着数据通过的宽度是，这是很多手势，但基本上你可以每个数字有32位。
on a chip, plug it into your CPU that you had built, and you would sit there and clock it, and you would have LEDs that represented the output. And he would write down after 10 clicks of the clock, like what the LEDs were after 20, after 30. And then they had to be right in order for you to pass and it represented the instructions actually being executed and the results being displayed um and you had no idea what was in his instruction set that was on his you know what the instruction set was because they gave it to you but you didn't know what specific program he had just run on your processor oh i see so yeah so i think i mean so from and correct me if i'm wrong i think the reason why
你可以把两个数字加在一起。但你有64位数字。嗯，这意味着你必须做两次加法，你知道，每对一次。但就像你说的，你可以在FPGA中进行256位加法。所以一次加两个256位。如果你想做自定义的事情，比如，
you know one would want to program their own fpga is because when you work with just a regular processor you're doing things in serial and the processor can do anything you know you want it can do you know multiplication add division you know many other operations but uh but it's designed to do like to do any of those and it's not really balanced one way or the other or i guess it is balanced it's not biased one way or the other and so if you need to do you know 40 add operations they're just all going to queue up one after another um now the processor will try to do like out of order execution and you know processes have gotten very complex but the reality is you know you need to add an entire array of numbers at once that's the way that's the way your program is designed or your the algorithm you want to create
哦，我想把这个相乘，加到之前的结果上，也做这个只有我才有的其他自定义事情，处理器不会有那种特殊逻辑。处理器有时确实有专门的逻辑，如果它不是太专门，而且他们认为这对每个人都有用。
its design then with an fpga you can literally have eight copies of the ad, you know, mechanic all running at the same time. Yeah. So it's like a really good idea. So like if you have like a 32 bit processor and you want to add two 64 bit numbers, right? So the 32 bit processor there means like the width of the data coming through is, this is a lot of hand-waving, but basically that you can have 32 bits per number
但FPGA可以拥有你想要的任何逻辑。所以它可以做疯狂的、没有意义的自定义事情，并且因为时钟的工作方式不是像这个东西喂给那个东西喂给那个东西喂给那个东西那样，它可以只是像我想要一次性做所有这些事情，所有这些事情同时发生。是啊，完全正确。所以这就是为什么你会拥有FPGA的原因。而且它会变得有点……我们可以深入探讨很多历史和东西以及表示它的方式，
and you can add two of those numbers together. But you have 64 bit numbers. Well, that means you have to do the adding twice, you know, once for each pairing. But like you said, you could in an FPGA have 256 bit adding. So add 256 bits twice at one time. And if you wanted to do custom things like,
但我认为我实际上要跳过它，因为我认为它最终会变得有点无聊。关于FPGA我还要提到的另一件事是，它节省了很多电力，对吧？我的意思是，正如我们所讨论的，处理器是一台通用机器，有许多许多不同的指令，它实际上极其
oh, I want to multiply this, add it to the previous result, and also do this other custom thing that's only to me, a processor won't have that special logic. Processors sometimes do have specialized logic if it's not too specialized and they think it's useful to everyone.
复杂，并且有所谓的流水线，它可以在同一时间处理几条指令。但如果你正在工作，你知道，构建手机或小型设备，你知道你想把它放在车里或类似的东西，那么电力就成了问题。所以，你知道，用FPGA编写你的东西可能会使电池运行一小时或四小时或更长时间的区别，对吧？是啊，还有其他事情，你知道，处理器只是不擅长。
But an FPGA can have whatever logic you want. So it can do custom things that are crazy and don't make sense and do them all in parallel all at once because there isn't uh the way the clocking works it isn't like this thing feeds to that thing feeds to that thing feeds to that thing by necessity it can just be like I want to do all this stuff at once all at the same time yeah exactly and so that is the reason why you would you know have FPGA. And it's going to get a little... We could go into a lot of the history and stuff and ways of representing it,
因为处理器的想法是它就像设置，无论他们把什么门放进处理器，因为处理器和FPGA在根本上都是某种门。无论他们把什么放进处理器，因为处理器和FPGA在根本上都是某种门，无论他们把什么放进处理器，他们选择一组门，这就是你得到的全部。所以他们必须为很多情况进行优化，这样他们才能把它卖给很多人，而且他们不知道你要做什么。但FPGA只是门的原始集合，所以你可以拿走那组门并在其中构建相同的处理器。而且他们实际上确实那样做了。
but I think I'm actually going to skip over it because I think it'll end up being kind of boring. One other thing I'll mention about the FPGA is that it saves a lot of power, right? I mean, as we talked about, the processor is a general-purpose machine that has many, many different instructions, and it's actually extremely
但我认为我实际上会跳过它，因为我觉得它最终会有点无聊。关于FPGA，我还要提的一点是，它非常省电，对吧？我的意思是，正如我们所讨论的，处理器是一种通用机器，拥有许多许多不同的指令，而且它实际上非常
complex and does has what's called a pipeline where it can be working on several instructions at the same time but if you're working on you know building a phone or a small device that you know you want to put in your car or something like that then power becomes an issue and and so you know writing your stuff in FPGA might make the difference between something running for an hour on battery or four hours or longer, right? Yeah, and there's other things that, you know, processors just don't do good at
复杂，并且确实拥有所谓的流水线，可以同时处理多条指令。但如果你正在构建手机或小型设备，比如你想把它放在车里之类的，那么功耗就成了一个问题。所以，用FPGA编写程序可能决定了设备是靠电池运行一小时，还是四小时甚至更久，对吧？是的，还有其他一些处理器不擅长的事情，
because the idea with a processor is it's like set, like whatever gates they put into a processor, because processors and FPGAs are both kind of gates fundamentally. Whatever they put into a processor because processors and FPGAs are both kind of gates fundamentally whatever they put into a processor they select one set of gates and that's all you get and so they have to optimize for a lot of cases so they can sell it to a lot of people and they don't know what you're going to do but the FPGA is just the raw collection of gates so you could take that collection of gates and build the same processor in it. And they actually do that.
因为处理器的理念是固定的，无论他们在处理器中放入什么门电路——因为从根本上讲，处理器和FPGA都是由门电路组成的——无论他们放入什么，他们都只能选择一套门电路，而这就是你所能得到的全部。因此，他们必须针对多种情况进行优化，以便卖给更多的人，而他们并不知道你会用它做什么。但FPGA只是原始的门电路集合，所以你可以利用这些门电路构建出同样的处理器。他们实际上确实是这样做的。
It's called like a soft core. So you can take an ARM processor like is in your cell phone and manifest it in an FPGA. So arrange the collection of gates in FPGA to be an ARM processor. And if you want like extra floating point ability, you could add it in.
这被称为软核。所以你可以拿一个像你手机里那样的ARM处理器，并在FPGA中实现它。也就是说，在FPGA中排列门电路的集合，使其成为一个ARM处理器。如果你需要额外的浮点运算能力，你也可以把它加进去。
If you wanted extra like, you know, like an extra wide pipeline, you could add that part in or take parts out. Oh, interesting. That's what the field programmable part is about is like in the field, not in the factory. Like you can change the combination of gates. So you can bring in and drop out your own processor or even things which we wouldn't normally do in a processor oh i always wondered where the field came from and yeah it makes sense like the field as opposed to the factor i like that so we can get into yeah it's it's a long discussion talking about like the kind of actual like engineering things behind this and what happens but you can define like an fpga to do any kind of things you
如果你需要额外的，你知道，比如一个超宽的流水线，你可以把那部分加进去或者去掉某些部分。哦，有意思。这就是“现场可编程”部分的含义，是在现场，而不是在工厂。你可以改变门电路的组合。所以你可以引入并移除你自己的处理器，甚至是一些我们通常不会在处理器中做的事情。哦，我一直想知道“现场”这个词是从哪来的，这很有道理，现场相对于工厂，我喜欢这个。所以我们可以深入探讨，这是一个很长的讨论，谈论这背后的实际工程问题以及会发生什么，但你可以定义一个FPGA来做任何你
might want to do in a processor or things which you wouldn't want to do in a processor and the ways that you kind of program them like write the programs one is we were talking about like logic gates and logic gates have symbols um and you can kind of draw a circuit a schematic that describes what you want the fpga to. So I want it to look at switch number one and switch number two. So switch being, as an example, like a light switch. So I only want to turn on the lights in my living room if both light switch one is on and light switch two is on. So I have an AND gate that looks at light switch one and light switch two, ANDs them together, and the output goes to determine if the light is going to be on or off.
可能想在处理器中做的事情，或者你不想在处理器中做的事情。关于如何编程，也就是编写程序，一种方式是我们刚才谈到的逻辑门，逻辑门有符号，你可以画一个电路图，描述你想要FPGA做什么。比如我想让它查看开关1和开关2。开关就是一个例子，比如电灯开关。我只想在开关1和开关2都打开时才打开客厅的灯。所以我有一个与门（AND gate），它查看开关1和开关2，将它们进行“与”运算，输出结果决定灯是开还是关。
And you could draw a little picture of that, and the FPGA would be able to replicate that logic. But as you get to bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger devices and more complex logic, those gates become even worse than writing an assembly code, like even lower level. So then what they have is some sort of what they call hardware definition language.
你可以画一张小图，FPGA就能复制那种逻辑。但当你面对越来越大的设备和更复杂的逻辑时，这些门电路甚至比编写汇编代码还要糟糕，级别更低。所以他们有一种所谓的硬件描述语言。
So you'll hear VHDL or Verilog. And VHDL and Verilog are, without getting into specifics on there, are ways of describing how the FPGA should function and how things should have, you could use, I want to add what's in place number one to place number two when the clock ticks so every time the clock ticks whatever's in location one and location two add them together and put them in location three every time i get a clock tick oh i see so
你会听到VHDL或Verilog。VHDL和Verilog是——在不深入细节的情况下——描述FPGA应该如何运作以及事物应该如何发生的方式。你可以使用它，比如：当时钟跳动时，我想把位置1的内容加到位置2。所以每次时钟跳动，无论位置1和位置2里有什么，把它们加在一起并放入位置3，每次时钟跳动我都会这样做。哦，我明白了，所以
and so it implements the ad operation i guess for you right so it determines how to configure the technology inside the FPGA to basically do the add operations every time you have a clock tick so that's one of the things that's interesting about FPGAs versus processors is that an FPGA like you have to talk about the clock so in the processor you talk about like oh my clock speed is 16 megahertz or one gigahertz and that means that like some operation an operation that completes in one cycle completes in one one millionth of a second for a megahertz and i can count how long a certain set of operations will take so if you need to do something really fast you need to know how long each instruction takes when fpj it's even more prevalent that you have to think about long each instruction takes. When FPGA, it's even more prevalent that
它为你实现了加法运算，对吧？所以它决定了如何配置FPGA内部的技术，以便在每次时钟跳动时执行加法运算。这就是FPGA与处理器相比有趣的地方之一，因为在FPGA中你必须谈论时钟。在处理器中，你谈论的是“哦，我的时钟速度是16兆赫兹或1吉赫兹”，这意味着某个操作，一个在一个周期内完成的操作，在1兆赫兹下会在一百万分之一秒内完成，我可以计算出一组特定的操作需要多长时间。所以如果你需要做非常快的事情，你需要知道每条指令需要多长时间。在FPGA中，这一点更为普遍，你必须考虑
you have to think about clocks and how fast your clock is running and that each time the clock ticks, because you're kind of defining this pipeline, like a step A, I want to do this, step B, I want to do this, and step C, I want to do this. So every time the clock ticks, things are moving down the pipeline, but the next set of things are coming in right behind them. And that's for what you call kind of like streaming operations So FPGAs are used heavily and in streaming operations like if you imagine a video camera Has data coming in every time it takes a picture so a video camera is just taking lots of pictures one right after the other and
你必须考虑时钟以及时钟运行的速度，并且每次时钟跳动时，因为你是在定义这个流水线，比如步骤A，我想做这个；步骤B，我想做这个；步骤C，我想做这个。所以每次时钟跳动，事物都在流水线中向下移动，但下一组事物紧随其后。这就是所谓的流式操作。所以FPGA被大量用于流式操作，比如如果你想象一个摄像机，每次拍照时都有数据进来，所以摄像机只是一个接一个地拍摄很多照片，并且
Those pictures just keep coming in and coming in and coming in and coming in and in a processor if you spend slightly too long Processing one of those frames all of a sudden all those other frames after you get pushed down the line and you end up with a problem and an fpga you're defining that like every i'm doing this then this then this and those frames just keep feeding in and you it's doing the same thing pretty much every time and um yeah it can't really get backed up because there's no pipeline or buffer well it's like you're but you've no you define it so strictly right so it's not like there's oh i see there's not it's not like branching right like oh if i see you know the color blue do this if i see the color green do this you know you don't do those
那些照片不断地涌入。在处理器中，如果你处理其中一帧的时间稍微长了一点，突然间后面所有的帧都被推到了后面，你就会遇到问题。而在FPGA中，你定义了“我正在做这个，然后是这个，然后是这个”，那些帧只是不断地输入，它每次做的几乎都是同样的事情。嗯，是的，它真的不会积压，因为没有流水线或缓冲区。好吧，就像你……但你定义得非常严格，对吧？所以不像是有……哦，我明白了，不像是有分支，对吧？比如“哦，如果我看到蓝色，做这个；如果我看到绿色，做这个”，你知道，你不会做那些
kinds of things fpga is fpga is much more about doing like a known set of operations like i want to you know divide every pixel by you know three and then add it to what the value of the previous pixel was so it's kind of like you want to define that and we talked previous about like gpu programming and how gpus don't like having branches in them right because when you do general purpose gpu programming the branches make it more difficult to kind of to do and so fbgas are are similar in that regard they're really good for when you know precisely what you want to do every time and you don't have a lot of complex logic and and algorithm around it so so that that talks about what it's really what about yeah like if you have so if you're writing this VHDL or Verilog and
类型的事情。FPGA更多的是关于执行一组已知的操作，比如“我想把每个像素除以3，然后把它加到前一个像素的值上”。所以这有点像你想要定义它。我们之前谈到了GPU编程，以及GPU不喜欢有分支，对吧？因为当你进行通用GPU编程时，分支使事情变得更难处理。所以FPGA在这方面很相似，它们非常适合当你精确地知道每次想做什么，并且周围没有复杂的逻辑和算法时。所以这谈到了它真正是关于什么的。是的，比如如果你在写VHDL或Verilog，并且
you so it sounds like you're almost writing arithmetic like add these two registers and do this how do you specify like these things can be done together but this thing needs the other thing I mean does it figure out all the data dependencies for you so partly right you're defining yeah so you're defining together, but this thing needs the other thing. I mean, does it figure out all the data dependencies for you? So partly, right, you're defining, yeah, so you're defining, like, oh, here's kind of, like, this component, and this component feeds into this component. So kind of like functions, right? So that's the equivalent. But it is a data flow language, right? So you're describing how the data flows through the system, and so you you're describing that flow and it is something kind of starkly different from writing a imperative
听起来你几乎是在写算术，比如“把这两个寄存器相加并做这个”。你如何指定这些事情可以一起完成，但这件事需要另一件事？我的意思是，它能为你计算出所有的数据依赖关系吗？所以部分正确，你是在定义……是的，你是在定义，比如“哦，这是这个组件，这个组件输入到这个组件”。所以有点像函数，对吧？所以这是等价的。但它是一种数据流语言，对吧？所以你是在描述数据如何流经系统，你是在描述那种流动，这与编写命令式
program uh it's much more functional programming kind of style okay so so the reason why like fpjs are good it's like we talked about that you know doing things in parallel so you have one processor so you can add one set of numbers but if you wanted to do like 10 of those at the same time you might have like 10 cores in your processor then you could do it but like an fpga if you're doing some simple thing you could just create a hundred of these cores where a core does some very basic operation over and over again and you can just keep creating more and more and more of them and so you can get that parallelism very easy and for like we said certain sets of algorithms where it's very set what you want to do and you you just want to compute it and you want to do it really fast and over and over and over again um taking time to implement that
程序截然不同。它更像是一种函数式编程风格。好的，所以FPGA之所以好的原因，就像我们谈到的，是并行处理。你有一个处理器，所以你可以加一组数字，但如果你想同时做10组，你可能需要在处理器中有10个核心，然后你就可以做到。但像FPGA，如果你在做一些简单的事情，你可以直接创建一百个这样的核心，其中一个核心一遍又一遍地执行一些非常基本的操作，你可以不断地创建更多。所以你可以很容易地获得那种并行性。对于我们所说的某些算法，当你非常确定你想做什么，并且你只是想计算它，想非常快地一遍又一遍地做它时，花时间在FPGA中实现该
algorithm in fpga can get you a lot of speed. Gotcha. Yeah, it also affects the power greatly. A lot of the smartphones now do MPEG decompression on, well, not an FPGA, but on, actually, how does that work? So if you write something in FPGA, can you turn that into a processor? Yes. Okay. Sort of. So a lot of those, they called like co-processors you'll
算法可以为你带来很大的速度提升。明白了。是的，它也极大地影响功耗。现在很多智能手机都在做MPEG解压，嗯，不是在FPGA上，而是在……实际上，那是怎么运作的？所以如果你在FPGA中写了东西，你能把它变成处理器吗？可以。好的。某种程度上。所以很多那些，他们称之为协处理器，你会
hear about um so like the mpeg encoder so it could be that that's just like another normal processor but more likely it's a very specialized processor that's called an asic and i don't know what asic stands for actually something i see which is integrated circuit i will look it up right now okay all right good so basically So basically in ASIC, you can take an FPGA description, a VHDL description, and synthesize an FPGA, which means figure out how to take this field programmable,
听到，比如MPEG编码器，所以它可能只是另一个普通的处理器，但更有可能是一个非常专业的处理器，叫做ASIC。我其实不知道ASIC代表什么，某种IC，也就是集成电路。我现在就查一下。好的，好的。所以基本上，在ASIC中，你可以采用FPGA描述、VHDL描述，并合成一个FPGA，这意味着弄清楚如何采用这种现场可编程的、
this reprogrammable set of gates that you can interlink in different ways to represent the logic that I've defined in my VHDL program. But by the same token, the tool could also say take that set of logic and determine the set of masks you would need to make to etch away at the silicon to actually make a custom chip out of silicon that does that one specific thing but once you do that
这种可重新编程的门电路集合，你可以以不同的方式互连它们，以表示我在VHDL程序中定义的逻辑。但同样地，该工具也可以说“采用那组逻辑并确定你需要制作的一组掩模，以蚀刻硅片，从而实际制造出一个定制的硅芯片，专门做那一件特定的事情”。但一旦你这样做，
asic stands for application specific integrated circuit, which I don't know what that means. So like I said, so it's like once you make an ASIC, that's it. Like you can't change it anymore. And it involves a lot of engineering costs to kind of determine how to go down to the actual gates and determine I only want these sets of gates and it's not reconfigurable. And once you make it, that's it. And you use it for a specific purpose. And so that's probably what like that MPEG chip is about.
ASIC代表专用集成电路（Application Specific Integrated Circuit），我不知道那是什么意思。所以就像我说的，一旦你制造了ASIC，就是这样了。你不能再改变它了。它涉及大量的工程成本来确定如何深入到实际的门电路，并确定“我只想要这些门电路”，而且它不是可重构的。一旦你制造了它，就是这样了。你把它用于特定的目的。所以这可能就是那个MPEG芯片的情况。
So somebody wrote this description and VHDL of how to do a portion of the MPEG encoding process really, really fast. And then they actually went and had a specific silicon chip made that does just that and then they put it in all the smartphones i see so an fpga would be like the first step to that like the prototyping step before moving to an asic but it could also be that you asic is too expensive for your need and so you just continue to use an fpga so like an asic per unit like per chip would be a lot cheaper because it's doing you know it's like made and only does one thing but like the initial cost
所以有人用VHDL写了这个描述，关于如何非常非常快地执行MPEG编码过程的一部分。然后他们实际去制造了一个专门做这件事的硅芯片，然后把它放进所有的智能手机里。我明白了，所以FPGA就像是通往那个的第一步，即原型设计步骤，但在转向ASIC之前。但也可能是ASIC对你的需求来说太贵了，所以你继续使用FPGA。所以ASIC每单位，即每个芯片，会便宜得多，因为它只是……你知道，它是制造出来的，只做一件事。但初始成本
like you'd have to buy thousands of chips i see you can't just like go buy one so maybe this uh going back to this the first news story about coin uh i guess maybe they will you know take this pre-order money that we give them and uh and put the logic for switching the credit card numbers and things like that on asic yeah so they could does that make sense okay i mean i don't know that that's what they're doing but yeah right it is like an example of yeah what what you could do gotcha so like there are some much smaller than an fpga that does the same thing i mean is it is it vastly different or is it about so so yeah i would say that yeah like if you had an equivalent how big of an fpga do you need to hold a set of operations versus an asic the asics can be much smaller because the fpga needs to have all this
比如你必须购买数千个芯片。我明白了，你不能只是去买一个。所以也许这个……回到关于Coin的第一个新闻故事，我想也许他们会，你知道，拿走我们给他们的预购资金，并把切换信用卡号码之类的逻辑放在ASIC上。是的，所以他们可以……这有道理吗？好的，我的意思是，我不知道他们是否在这样做，但是的，这确实是一个你可以做什么的例子。明白了。所以有些比FPGA小得多，做同样的事情。我的意思是，它有很大不同吗，还是关于……所以，是的，我会说，如果你有一个等效的，你需要多大的FPGA来容纳一组操作，而ASIC可以小得多，因为FPGA需要有所有这些
extra routing and switching logic to be able to be reconfigured and you don't need that in the asic you're hardwiring one specific configuration okay um so some of the things that make it difficult is there this fpga programming falls in kind of a weird space right so computer science people like you know jason was describing himself would be very uh you know distraught to learn about all these details they had to pay attention to about clocking and interfacing with external power and those kind of things um and electrical engineers don't always enjoy programming some do but some know, don't really want to do programming. And so this FPGA programming falls in between those two disciplines. And sometimes it's hard to find people who want to or have the ability to do it. And it can be difficult sometimes to take the logic of like a
额外的路由和切换逻辑才能被重新配置，而你在ASIC中不需要那个，你是在硬连线一个特定的配置。好的，嗯，一些使其困难的事情是，这种FPGA编程处于一种奇怪的空间，对吧？计算机科学专业的人，就像Jason描述他自己那样，会非常苦恼于学习所有他们必须注意的关于时钟、与外部电源接口以及这类事情的细节。而电气工程师并不总是喜欢编程，有些人喜欢，但有些人知道，并不真的想做编程。所以这种FPGA编程介于这两个学科之间。有时很难找到想要或有能力做这件事的人。而且有时很难将C程序的逻辑，并实际确定如何在FPGA编程和VHDL的约束下做同样的事情。明白了，是的，我的意思是，回到Patrick的观点，对吧，你想要在FPGA中做这件事的原因是为了获得某种并行性或速度优势之类的。所以你不能只是把你带有for循环之类的C程序直接放入VHDL或Verilog中，因为你会失去所有的好处，所以
C program and actually determine how to do the same thing with the constraints of FPGA programming and VHDL. Gotcha, yeah, I mean, to Patrick's point, right, like the reason why you'd want to do this in FPGA is to get some kind of like parallelism or speed benefit or something like that. So you can't just take your C program with the four loops and things like that and just put it directly into VHDL or verilog because you lose all of your benefits so
所以当你转向像FPGA这样的东西时，你必须考虑数据依赖性，比如“我可以同时执行这个for循环的所有迭代吗？”或者如果我只能同时执行其中的一部分，我该如何构建我的操作，以便我知道它们在下一批开始时及时完成，诸如此类。是的，而且测试非常困难。所以就像我说的，FPGA，你知道，接口……没有像处理器那样处理与外部世界的接口的所有特定逻辑，但在FPGA上，它们旨在以不同的方式使用，所以你经常必须担心与外部世界的接口，并确定你想要测试的输入集。所以，如果你的FPGA的输入之一不是0或1，而是
so when you go to something like an fpga you have to think about uh the data dependency like can i do all iterations of this for loop at the same time or if i can only do part of them at the same time uh how do i structure my operations so that i know they're finished in time for the next batch to start things like that yep and testing is is pretty hard so like i said fpga's uh you know interface don't have like the processors handle interfacing with outside world with all this specific logic but like on an fpga they're meant to be used in different ways and so often you have to worry about uh interfacing the outside world and determining the set of inputs you want to test against so like what happens if one of the inputs to your fpga isn't zero or one but is
漂浮不定，你的算法会发生什么，你如何测试它？等等，那是什么意思？它怎么可能不是0或1？所以，好吧，我们会跑题，但没关系，一会儿就好。所以如果一个处理器，为了方便起见，运行在5伏电压下，所以你用5伏电压给它供电，那么当它看到一个被称为输入引脚的给定引脚时，如果该引脚接地，那么它说它是0。如果它是5伏，它说它是1。
floating around what happens to your like your algorithm and how do you test that? Wait, what does that mean? How could it not be zero or one? So, okay, we'll get sidetracked, but it's okay for a second. So if a processor just for ease is running at five volts, so you powered it with five volts, then when it sees a given pin that is called an input pin, if that pin is at ground, then it says it's a zero. If it's at five volts, it says it's one.
所以这运作得很好。数字信号说它需要是0或1。对。但如果你没有连接任何东西到那个引脚，而引脚只是受到电磁干扰，并且它在0伏到8伏到2伏到6伏之间变化，哦，哦，你在编程时必须处理这个问题。所以，是的，所以它
So that works really well. Digital says it needs to be either zero or one. Right. But what happens if you don't connect anything to that pin and the pin is just getting electromagnetic interference and it's varying from zero volts to eight volts to two volts to six volts oh oh you have to you have to deal with that while you're programming that so so yeah so like it
可能只是在你面前乱跳，对吧？而且通常由于FPGA有时想要处理这类事情的方式，你必须处理这类事情。而在处理器中，人们假设你不想处理这类事情，所以他们通常构建电路板，使得这种情况不会发生。明白了。嗯，还有，工具……仍然没有真正好的开源工具用于编程FPGA和合成，即相当于编译器的东西，那个获取你的VHDL并确定“这是我将如何编程一组逻辑门”的东西。甚至我也四处寻找，因为我想，
could just be flapping around on you right like and typically because of the nature of the way fpgas sometimes want to handle those kinds of things you have to handle those kinds of things versus like in a processor people assume you don't want to handle those kinds of things you have to handle those kinds of things versus like in a processor people assume you don't want to handle those kinds of things so they typically build the board such that doesn't happen gotcha um also the tools like still there isn't really good like open source tools for programming fpgas and synthesizing that like what amounts to the compiler, the thing that takes your VHDL and determines here's how I would program a set of logic gates. And even I looked around because I wanted to,
作为一种爱好，真正地编程。我过去为了工作相关的事情做过一些FPGA编程，但作为爱好，我想做。而且电路板通常很贵，很难买到一个并实际尝试一下。而且工具本身非常昂贵。所以这些编译你编写的FPGA程序的工具需要数千美元。而且它们通常是学生版或免费版。甚至还有一些工具，
as a hobby, really program. I've done some FPGA programming in the past for work-related stuff, but as a hobby, I wanted to do it. And the boards are typically pretty expensive to get one and actually try it out. And the tools themselves are very expensive. So thousands of dollars for these tools that compile these FPGA programs that you write. And often they're student versions or free versions. And there are even some tools,
我以前用过几个，非常有限，你可以使用受限的C语言集来定义算法，它会为你合成FPGA。所以它会获取你的C语言，将其编译为VHDL，然后获取该VHDL并将其传递给这些工具之一。然后该工具将制作FPGA。这些正在变得更好。有一天人们希望，你将能够只用C++编程FPGA。但如果你这样做，你如何告诉它，你知道，它应该有三个加法模块而不是两个？是的，所以有特殊的预处理器标签你可以添加
and I've used a couple of them before, very limitedly, where you actually can use a restricted set of C language to define an algorithm and it'll synthesize the FPGA for you. So it'll take your C language, compile it to VHDL and then take that VHDL and pass it into one of these tools. And that tool will make the FPGA. And those are getting better. And one day people hope that like, you'll just be able to program an FPGA in C++. But if you do that, how do you tell it that, you know, that it should have, you know, three add modules instead of two? Yeah, so there's special kind of pre-processor tags you add
并说，比如，某种哈希，你知道，井号“并行8”，然后是一个for循环，对吧？所以并行执行这个for循环的8次迭代。我是编的，但那将是你所做的一个例子。对，对，是的，你注释你的代码来帮助。这太酷了。是的，我正在四处查看，在Google购物上，是的，看起来你需要几百美元才能买到FPGA，这其实还不算太坏。不，他们有一些更小的，不到一百美元的。所以，是的，嗯，但与……你知道，我玩过小微处理器并编写
and say like, kind of hash, you know, pound in parallel eight and then a for loop right so do eight iterations of this for loop in parallel i made that up but like that would be an example of what you right right yeah so you annotate your code to help right that's pretty cool yeah i'm looking i'm looking around on on uh shopping google shopping yeah it looks like it'll run you a few hundred dollars to get fpg which actually isn't that bad no they have some they have some smaller ones that are sub a hundred dollars so so yeah um but versus like you know i've played around with little microprocessors and writing
C代码，像Arduino风格，你可以花20美元买一个Arduino，或者上面使用的处理器，你可以花1.30美元或1.50美元左右买到。是的，那是真的。所以有趣的事情之一是，你知道，很多时候你把FPGA和处理器配对，因为它们都有各自的优势。所以你可以要么像串行通信那样与FPGA通信。或者通常有趣的是，当你进入C语言中的内存地址时，你实际上是在设置微处理器上的某些引脚
c code like arduino style and you can get an arduino for you know twenty dollars or the processor that is used on there you can get get for like $1.30 or $1.50 or something. Yeah, that's true. So one of the interesting things is, you know, a lot of times you pair an FPGA with a processor because they both have their advantages. And so you can either talk like, you know, serial to the FPGA and communicate with it. Or oftentimes what's interesting is when you go to a memory address in NC, then you are actually setting some pins on a microprocessor
来保存你指定的地址。所以以二进制形式，这些引脚将代表你指定的地址。然后另一组引脚将开始采用你写入该地址的数据值，例如。所以你拥有的一些内存被称为内部内存。所以当你这样做时，那些引脚上什么都不会发生。你只会写入内部RAM。
to hold the address that you specified. So in binary, these pins will represent that address you specified. And then another set of pins will start taking on the values of the data you write to that address, for instance. So some of the memory you have is what's called internal memory. So when you do that, nothing will happen on those pins. You'll just write to internal RAM.
但随后地址空间的其他部分，它被称为，将映射到这些暴露在处理器外部的引脚上。当这种情况发生时，FPGA实际上可以坐在那里。所以你可以与FPGA交谈的一种方式是说，在地址5000，当你放入数字3时，我要去把这盏灯打开。当你写入数字4时，我要去把它关掉。然后你实际上可以通过写入特定值到特定地址来与它交谈。这在编写设备驱动程序时很常见。我一直想知道这个，如果你尝试设置连接到FPGA指令输出的引脚，会发生什么？我的意思是，世界会崩溃吗？不，它会被处理。但是，是的，你必须小心。所以会发生什么？我的意思是，什么都不会发生，我想？所以，如果你——我其实不确定会发生什么。所以如果你有两个输出引脚只是连接到彼此，它们会试图驱动彼此。所以我猜一个会赢。
But then other parts of the address space, it's called, will map to these pins that are exposed on the outside of the processor. And when that happens, the FPGA could actually be sitting there. So one way you can talk to an FPGA is to say like, at address 5000, when you put the number three, I'm going to go turn this light on. And when you write the number four, I'm going to go turn it off. And then you can actually talk to it by writing kind of specific values to specific addresses. And that's a lot you'll see common even when you write like device drivers are handled that way. I always wondered this, if you try to set the pins that are
哦，我明白了。所以那会采用其中一个的值，或者介于两者之间的某个值。我不记得了。好吧，我猜也许抱歉，我问的问题是，你可以通过FPGA向后走吗？如果像你不是设置输入引脚然后读取输出引脚，如果你设置输出引脚，会发生什么？电流会通过FPGA向后流动吗？不会。好的。通常，它是这样配置的，输出被配置为三种状态之一，即输入、输出，或者所谓的断开，即高阻抗状态，无论你做什么，否则它都不会影响它。所以当它是输入时，它试图读取该值。所以任何事情都可能发生在那个东西上。当它是输出时，如果两个东西都是输出，它们会竞争。而且通常内置了电路来保护它们免受电流向后流动的影响。
connected to the output of an FPGA instruction, what happens then? I mean, does, like, the world collapse? No, it's handled. But, yeah, like, you've got to be careful. So what would happen? Like, nothing would happen, I guess? So, like, if you – I'm not actually sure what would happen. So if you had two output pins connected just to each other, they'll try to drive each other. So I guess one would win.
但发生了什么，线路上出现了所谓的争用，所以无论那两个之间的那段电线是什么，它是0还是1，是正极还是接地，都是不确定的。明白了。但是的，它们通常保护自己免受电流向后流动的影响，那会很糟糕。是的，对，好的，这有道理。所以就像我说的，嗯，你知道，处理器和FPGA可以嵌入在同一个设备上。你也可以在FPGA内部拥有一个处理器版本，所以FPGA的某一部分目前代表一个处理器，然后其他部分是其他东西。哦，有意思。这被称为软核。所以你可以把像ARM处理器这样的东西嵌入到你的FPGA中。现在人们甚至谈论做一些事情，比如如果我进入不同的操作模式，让一个处理器来
Oh, I see. And so that would take on whatever value of one of them or some value in between i i don't remember well i guess maybe sorry the question i was asking is can you do and can you go through an fpga backwards like what what happens if you like instead of setting the input pins and then reading the output pins, if you set the output pins, what would happen? Would the electricity go backwards through the FPGA? No. Okay. Typically, so it's configured where the outputs are configured in one of three,
加载一个不同的程序，就像在FPGA上一样。所以重新编程FPGA在某种东西的中间以不同的方式表现。哦，哇。所以你去观看视频，FPGA重新编程为MPEG解码器。没错。现在我正在录制视频，所以它切换为MPEG编码器。哇，这太棒了。现在我正在做别的事情。
a pin is configured in one of three states to be an input, an output, or what's called disconnected, like a high impedance state where no matter what you do, otherwise it's not going to affect it. So when it's an input, it's trying to read the value. So anything can happen on the thing. When it's an output, if two things are an output, they'll compete. And typically there's circuitry built in to protect them from the current flowing backwards.
为什么这没有普及？这听起来是个好主意。我的意思是，我认为这只是非常困难的事情之一。比如如何弄清楚，你不仅必须编程FPGA一次，现在你还必须弄清楚所有这些不同程序的代码，然后何时切换。明白了，明白了。
But what happened, there's what's called contention on the line so like whatever that piece of wire between the two will it's undetermined whether it'll be a zero or a one whether it'll be positive or ground gotcha but yeah they typically protect themselves from having current to flow backwards that would be bad yeah right okay that makes sense so like i said um you know a processor and an fpga could be embedded together on a device you can also have a version of the processor inside of an fpga so some part of the fpga is currently representing a processor and then other parts other things oh interesting and that's called soft cores and so you can embed like an ARM processor inside your FPGA. And now people even talk about doing things like if I enter different modes of operation having a processor to
而且可能只是随着技术越来越好，比如与其在两种不同模式之间重新编程，你只是拥有一个大两倍的FPGA，然后你可以把它编程为同时成为两者。哦，真的，这有道理。所以，嗯，但人们谈论过它，并且围绕它有一些有趣的东西。好吧，这非常酷。所以从你教我们的东西来看，我们应该能够去Digikey买一些很酷的电机和电子产品和FPGA，然后大干一场。这太棒了。我可能会尝试这个。
load a different program as it were on the FPGA. So reprogram the FPGA in the middle of something to behave differently. Oh wow. So you go to watch a video and the FPGA reprograms to be an MPEG decoder. That's right. And now I'm recording a video, so it switches to be an MPEG encoder. Wow, that's awesome. And now I'm doing something else.
是的，这不是我们平时的节目。比如我并没有真正经历VHDL或Verilog的优点，或者如何编程它们。听起来这两个之间真的没有任何竞争。是的，但希望它激发了一些兴趣或解释了它是什么。很多人听说过FPGA这个词，只是……兴趣或解释了它是什么，很多人听说过FPGA这个词，只是不知道它是什么，或者它做什么，或者它有什么不同。是的，是的，绝对，这太棒了。我一直想自己做一些机器人领域的事情，但我从来没有天赋去做它，所以也许这会是，即使只是
How come that isn't widespread? That sounds like an amazing idea. I mean, I think it's just one of those very difficult things to do. Like how to figure, not only do you have to program the FPGA once, now you have to like figure out the code for all these different ones and then when to switch. Gotcha, gotcha.
像如果它能去打开冰箱拿个三明治那么简单，或者类似的事情。但即使我必须给三明治贴标签，你知道，非常简单的事情，为了好玩而做它会很有趣，你知道。是的，那仍然把你的目标定得有点高。是的，我喜欢“如果我让一个LED灯闪烁”怎么样。是的，我猜那是真的。我可能应该从那里开始。好的。好的，酷。我想这就是节目了。
And then it might just be easier like as technology gets better and better, like instead of having reprogramming it between two different modes, you just have an FPGA that's twice as big and then you can program it to be both at the same time oh true that makes sense so um but people have talked about it and there's some interesting stuff around that well this is very cool so what from what you've taught us we should be able to go on digikey buy some cool motors and electronics and FPGA and go to town. That's pretty awesome. I might try this.
是的，非常感谢你帮助支撑这个节目。这是一个非常有趣的话题。我觉得它太棒了。好的。感谢我们所有的评论。人们鼓励我们回到麦克风前录制下一集。是的，绝对。这很难，对吧？因为，你知道，我们经历了很多变化。我实际上现在在城另一边工作。所以对我来说这是一个巨大的转变。
Yeah, this isn't our normal episode. Like I didn't really go through the merits of VHDL or Verilog or how to program them. It sounds like there aren't really any competition for these two. Yeah, but hopefully it sparked some interest or explained what it is. A lot of people have heard the term FPGA and just interest or explain what it is a lot of people have heard the term fbj and just don't know what it is or what it does or what how it's different yeah yeah definitely this is awesome i've always wanted to build to do something in the robotic space um on my own but uh i've never had the talent to do it so maybe this will be even just
而且实际上，是的，我们在家里安装了《车票之旅》（Ticket to Ride）。所以我们有火车不断经过。所以现在当我静音那个音频时，人们不会知道你在说什么。哦，天哪。好的。但是的，我们有很多私人的事情。火车正经过我的房子。是的。
something as simple as like if it could just go and open the fridge and get a sandwich like like or something like that but even if I have to tag the sandwich you know something very simple it'd be fun to just do it for fun you know yeah that's still setting your sights a little high yes I like what if I an LED to blink on and off. Yeah, I guess that's true. I should probably start there. Okay. All right. Cool. I think that's a show.
现在你不能静音它了。没有让一切变得尴尬是不可能的。但是的，所以我有很多私人的事情发生，但我感谢大家的耐心，而且，你知道，我们做这个节目绝对有很多乐趣。我每集都学到一些全新的东西，我相信你们也是。所以，你知道，感谢所有的支持，祝你们玩得开心。好的。下次见。如果你制造了任何东西，你必须让我们知道。我想看照片。好的。
Yeah, thanks a lot for helping carry this show. It's a really interesting topic. I thought it was awesome. All right. And thanks for all our comments. People encouraging us to get back on their mics and record the next episode. Yeah, definitely. It's pretty hard, right? Because, you know, we've been going through a lot of changes. I've actually I actually work across town now. So it's a big transition for me.
再见。回头见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，
And actually, yeah, we installed Ticket to Ride in our house. And so we have trains going by constantly. So now when I mute that audio, people aren't going to know what you're talking about. Oh, dear. Okay. But yeah, we've had a lot of personal stuff. Trains are driving by my house. Yeah.
但你必须提供对我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Now you can't mute it. Not without everything being awkward. But yeah, so I've had a lot of personal stuff going on but i appreciate everybody's patience and uh you know we definitely have a lot of fun doing this show i learned something brand new every show uh and i'm sure you guys do too so uh you know thanks for all the support and uh have a good time all All right. Until next time. If you build anything, you have to let us know. I want to see pictures. All right.
现在你不能静音了。除非你想让一切变得尴尬。但总之，我最近有很多私事要处理，但我感谢大家的耐心。我们做这个节目确实很有趣，我每一期都能学到新东西，我相信你们也是。所以，感谢大家的支持，祝大家玩得开心。好的，下次见。如果你做出了什么东西，一定要告诉我们。我想看照片。好的。
Bye. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
再见。回头见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。《Programming Throwdown》采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，也可以进行重混、改编，
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。